You just want to play 40k. You just want it to be like 40k and
you want to create 40k, but
I want to I don't know what the this has to do with fighting
a lost war. Number one, we don't have to be as dumb as
dude. I love that Pisco and Connor started talking once a week
and Pisco is already at the point where he can see the pattern
of Connor just starts talking about totally irrelevant [__]
in the middle of like contended points.
Counterpoints is basically saying Fuentes and Hassan are equivalent.
Let's just let's keep looking. Let's see uh what we got here.
Okay, move the chat back on. Now we're on kick only. >> The
right policy, the right ball. >> Oh, hold on. The right
funding, >> but that ain't JD Vance. But but that ain't
JD Vance. >> They they're totally in favor of of gutting
any kind of regulation. That's one of the reasons why people
criticize the abundance agenda because they think that there's
some uh >> Okay, this will be about where we want to start.
All right. Now, it's going to be standard political talk for
about 15 minutes and then we'll get into that conversation, but
it's largely going to be like techno libertarian.
>> These are disgusting out of touch
degenerates who want who have like these visions of grander,
delusions of grandeur of colonizing Mars. Never going to happen.
And like, thank God that Joe was here to tell Pisco about this
to educate Pisco on this. Pisco now gets to look really smart
and it's all like Joe's video. The dark gothic manga video. Thank
God for Joe. >> Spreading their siege vision, son. >> What's
that? >> I said, "Damn, you lack vision, son. You think
we can't colonize Mars with some >> Not Not in the next
thousand years.
>> I think we could do it. >> Oh, I don't know if
that's true. I I actually don't know how possible colonizing
Mars is.
But that if Pisco is saying thousand years, then that's implying
that um that like there's some tech gap that exists that can't
be reconciled right now. I feel like I feel like it's not widely
disputed that that like
humans could colonize Mars like quite easily if they just focused
on it, right? Like if we were able to if you were able to snap
your fingers and control humanity, you could you could colonize
Mars, right?
Well, you have to terraform it. Yeah, but like I think we have
the resources. We have the capability. We just don't want to
do it right >> in the next century. But that's okay. >> You're
delusional.
>> You don't want you want to talk about politics or do
you want to talk about colonizing Mars? >> You're not going
to be able to terraform Mars in the next century. It's a delusional
idea that like we need to we can't we can't terraform. Okay.
What would you do? How would you colonize it? How would you make
it liveable for
biodome and uh what the the effects of gravity over a long period
of time. The lack of any protection from these ultra gamma whatever
radiation spikes all the time. The fact that like I thought you
don't you like nuke the [__] out of it. Isn't that
what you do? Cuz they're actually going to have a conversation
of terraforming Mars which is very funny. I thought you like
nuke the [__] out of it. Isn't that what you do?
You just nuke the out of it and you build up an ozone through
nuking it. I wasn't that a thing. I bet you build an atmosphere
by nuking. Am I crazy? I thought this was a thing. Anyway, we
keep going. >> There's no air to breathe. It's >> But
I I actually don't know what the what is entailed by wanting
to terraform Mars. I just know it's important. >> You know,
there there's no like significant atmosphere. This is not an
easy project. A biodome. Give me a break. Why? Why? To what end?
Why are we doing this if we can't make it a hospitable place
for more people? We're spending all these resources. It's a a
childish fantasy. Um, and we should start, if we're going to
start at all, by terraforming, how about Iran where they don't
have like reliable water right now? There's a crisis. Why not
like the Sahara on Earth? We can't even do that. So, this whole
thing, these are
>> I don't think I don't think that's a good argument for
Pisco, but I don't I don't know, man. And I don't know the >> metahumans
in the context of like Peter >> or they're
babies man babies like Elon Musk who every time he has a temper
tantrum he is doing unhinged
oh man China's kind of terraforming their desert. So is Egypt
but Egypt is like doing the most Egypt like
man I watched a video on how Egypt's trying to terraform the
Sahara.
It's goofy as Okay. It's like the least efficient, most goofy
[__] I've ever seen in my entire life. >> And
like high on ketamine half the time. And you want to give the
country to these people by electing JD Vance on your own lights
>> compared to the alternative. Depends on what the alternative,
>> which is like a standard Democrat like Gavin Newsome.
Yeah. Uh the standard Democrat like Gavin Newsome. Kla Harris
was a standard Democrat. Kla Harris was tweeting about gun control
30 days from the election, which was so [__] dumb
that I can't believe that you guys can't get your head out of
your own ass in reference to firearms. And then not just that,
uh also the uh what what is it? It's like uh the tax on unearned
capital gains or whatever. A wealth tax. You >> over the
fraud people over the fraud
>> freak out and turn think about it. But at the same time,
you have to understand how many centerleft
rich people
abandoned comma Harris at the last minute because she was proposing
a wealth tax.
>> I understand that, right? And by the >> I have
no reason to believe it. >> I have no reason to believe
that that >> was a profit.
>> Okay. When it come Well, yeah, I didn't believe the
proposal either. That's why I checked the box next to Kla Harris's
name. I also didn't think that she was gonna be able to get into
I didn't I didn't I didn't mean that. I meant like I have no
reason to believe that that significantly won the election. My
intuition is if we pull the wealth tax
>> wait. Okay, hold on. No, no, no, no, no. That's that's
not what um that's not what Conor's saying. Connor is saying
she lost momentum. She lost funding. She lost um she lost funding
to do like more advertising and stuff because she went with the
wealth tax and those people just went to >> tax that most
Americans would support
That's my intuition because whenever you ask Americans whenever
you ask Americans >> class Americans would support it.
Yeah. >> Yes. So I don't have any I have no reason to think
that Kla Harris's support of a wealth tax impacted negatively
her um results in the election. I have no reason to think that
that is an unpopular policy. >> But this this is exactly
okay. So so this is where like you don't believe or a couple
of weeks ago you didn't believe that we had principal differences.
This is where the rubber is going to meet the road. Okay. I was
raised to believe and sincerely believe that the average American
is a [__] dumbass who should not be let around power.
Okay? We elect technocratic elites. And by the way, our technocratic
elites kind of suck right now. They they they they do suck. They
probably always sucked, but they especially suck right now because
we can see what they think on Twitter. And half of them are dumb
asses, too. Okay. But
>> I don't know. Why? Why would you think the elected
>> Why would you think elected officials are a technocratic
elite?
>> I'm sorry. It seems like that's just obviously not true.
Like that, especially at least since MAGA, this just clearly
not true. You can't get elected as a technocratic elite elite
person right now. At least in the Republican side. >> What
we're supposed to
I can't think of a better face of the technocratic elite than
Marjgery Taylor Green. black technocratic elites who craft policy
that is good not just for them on an individual basis but it's
good for the economy it's good for Americans it's good for the
country it's good yeah that hasn't been your congress and for
like for a long time I do think there was a point where this
was probably true where it was sort of a technocratic elite who
were getting elected and then slowly that was like corrupted
out and it just became people who would chill for big businesses
not to do the whole oh big business controls congress kind of
thing but I think less and less it became about policy that works
for all Americans and more about policy that work more and more
about policy that works to build the American economy. Now, for
a long time, those incentives were totally aligned, right? Those
were really aligned and as you made these companies richer, America
got better. I think we're starting to see the disconnect where
increasing the profits of these companies is not tangibly increasing
the the quality of life of the American people. That's really
all we should be arguing about, right? Where did the incentives
start diverging where okay now incentivizing economic growth
at the cost of everything else is no longer improving lives broadly
in the way it was before that used to be the case. Now these
companies are offshoring. These companies are outsourcing. These
companies are doing everything they can to stop hiring American
workers and devalue that labor because it is the most expensive
thing on every balance sheet for every company on the planet
is having western labor.
So those those incentives have started to diverge. they've started
to to see western labor as the most costly, least required thing
on the planet. If that is the case, then prioritizing the e the
economy, big business, keeping all this stuff running, that's
not really in the broad American interest anymore. But that's
pretty obvious,
right? Okay. Yeah. I just But that I mean that seems obvious
to me national interest. That's the ideal of Republicanism. But
I feel like Republicans have abdicated their responsibility within
the past two or three generations where all they've done from
a technocratic policy standpoint is they've deregulated and cut
taxes and they've gone too far and they up our social fabric.
But I will remind you that this wasn't always the case. Real
quick, Teddy Roosevelt was a Republican. He set up the National
Park System. He was responsible for enforcing the Monroe Doctrine.
He was responsible for American military and diplomatic hedgeimonyy
within the western.
>> Okay. But if you go back to a time that is totally ahistorical
or sorry totally irrelevant to the current period, right? How
many Republicans today are like, "Oh yeah, Teddy Roosevelt's
who I model my opinions after."
How many?
Right. Like you're you're talking about a time that was cool
and is a part of Republican history. Maybe just like Abe Lincoln's
a part of Republican history. But as as as dumb as this, this
argument is as dumb as saying, well, actually, Democrats were
the ones who wanted to keep slavery. It's like, okay, that's
irrelevant to today's politics. That while that is true, and
I can acknowledge it's true, it is irrelevant. Please stop bringing
up irrelevant
Also, I need to take
Richard Nixon probably in a lot of people's eyes, one of the
most like malevolent presidents ever, was a rep.
Republican who established the EPA. It is possible for Republicans
to be technocrats. They just haven't done it in two generations.
>> Yeah. But it's so preposterous what you're talking about
right now because what is Theodore? Yes. Look at your examples.
Theodore Roosevelt. One of his like biggest accomplishment is
is what? Trust busting. These people want to further their trusts.
They want to further monopolize and centralize power behind um
you know this accumulation of capital and there why why are they
ped at people like Lena Khan and the casino financial protection
bureau and the DOJ starting these lawsuits about monopolies is
because they want to monopolize. So you cite Theodor Roosevelt
the people that you're trying to put in charge specifically don't
want that. You cite you know environmental policy both you know
theodore Roosevelt. >> Okay so Pisco is just on the exact
same side here or is on the exact same page. You're referencing
things that while a part of Republican history, while they are
true, are totally irrelevant to today's politics and totally
delusional to hold out hope for. This is like holding out hope
that Republicans are going to Oh, this is like holding out God,
is there a good example here? I can't think of a good example,
but this is basically like you are going to if you hold your
breath, you will die 100%. >> Well, national parks and
uh the EPA under Richard Nixon. Um the issue is only there are
parts of abundance that are like obviously true
like the whole thing about slashing housing regulation. Um like
that's obviously true. Obviously housing regulations need to
be busted up, right? So you have to be careful when you just
say the abundance agenda is bad because then basically all the
things described people think you're saying are bad. I mean just
talk about pieces that are bad.
I I think >> these guys want to get rid of all of these
environmental regulations. They are in favor of gutting the EPA.
They're in favor of, you know, drilling oil from the very last
um endangered species on the last marshland in the the whole
country. They don't give a [__] about the environment.
Um they they they're totally uh in favor of of gutting any kind
of regulation. That's one of the reasons why people criticize
the abundance agenda because they think that there's some uh
potential collusion between abundance libs and gutting environmental
regulations and these people who like Elon Musk have kind of
signaled, oh, we're kind of pseudo interested in in abundance.
Now, I don't think that that is a necessary entailment of the
abundance of genocide. I'm not I am not making that proposition,
but I'm just saying all of the great Republicans from a bygone
era that you're citing to, they are way more similar to your
average Democrat and the technocrats,
more like bureaucrats, capitalists,
um, major oligarchs that are running the country, the people
that you want to put in power, because that's your vision of
who is really controlling the the strings of JD Vance, they're
all against the [__] that you justed as like the
wonderful possibility for Republicans. And of course, we're just
in a whole different era when it comes to the Republican party.
It's like it doesn't even make sense to compare the Republican
party under the Roosevelt or Richard Nixon who's coming from
like California Republican and it's like a liberal Republican
in that sense to Pisco is Pisco is just way too kind a lot of
the time. Like Connor just said something totally
I have a hard time even like it's hard to start the conversation
unless you could point out that it is just
like so you should feel embarrassed for saying it. >> The
current modern Republican party. So on every level I think your
analysis
>> Okay, never mind. That's Listen, that's about as mean
as he's going to get. All right. On on literally every level
your analysis sucks. That's basically Conor's platform in a nutshell.
On every level you are wrong. You are you are you your analysis
sucks. Every part of you sucks. If the might if if the mightest
touch people weren't paying for your channel, you would not exist.
If you didn't suck Destiny's, you wouldn't exist. >> I
think I think Jeb and George aren't as lost as you might think
they are. Um and and by the way, they might not even be power
brokers anymore. The Iraq war might have tarnished George Bush's
legacy and might have tarnished his brother so much that >> they
hate JD Vance. They hate JD Vance.
>> Why JD Vance?
because he's part of this new wave of degenerate like um
in their minds this guy who is this guy JD Vance he's a nobody
he comes from Appalachia he's not part of the Bush dynasty he's
not coming from this like established uh you know lineage of
political heritage like George Bush is born in like New England
and they
have this kind of like more elitist
cultural connections and and they're in higher society His advance
is still Silicon Valley and isn't he Ivy League educated too
though? Like I I know what you're saying. >> No, all I'm
saying has roots. But I'm saying he's been >> they don't
view him as part of the club.
>> The Bushes and these neocons who are irrelevant right
now. They're
>> he went to Ohio State. Where'd he go to law school?
I forget. >> Irrelevant. They're totally irrelevant. They
don't view JD Vance as part of the club. And they're dying, Connor.
They're dying. They're not in control.
>> No, no, no, no. Hold on, hold on. This is This is where
I agree with you. Okay. Um and and >> oh, Yale. He went
to Yale. >> We should actually we should talk about this
because this is >> Yeah, I would I I for some reason I
thought Cornell, but >> the most important part. >> I
have two options from my perspective. And bear in mind, I'm irrelevant.
I'm talking to 100 people in my chat. Now, my chat is very generous.
Like, holy [__] they're generous. Um I I can't even
thank them enough uh for how much they donate to my chat. But
realistically what I have is I have 60 liberals and I got 40
conservatarian libertarians and they oil because they miss sane
Republicans. And you're saying sane Republicans are
endangered
borderline going extinct.
And I agree with you. Okay. I agree with you. >> Republicans
can't exist. That's the whole point. That's the whole point.
You could say you want real Republicans back and you could propose
some some vision for the future, but understand that between
listen
Republicans ask Pisco. Okay, actually I we should get this question
to Pisco at some point. What's further in the future? Sane Republicans
or an actual terraforming of Mars?
Which one? Cuz honestly, terraforming Mars seems pretty doable
than fixing the current Republican party. Sorry. More doable.
More do Yeah. in comparison to fixing the Republican party. Jesus
Christ, dude.
Like, it's broken. It is fundamentally broken. It needs to be
torn down and rebuilt entirely. And I don't think people I don't
think you're in a position economically where you can rebuild
on foundational like great principle. I don't think the country
is in a good place. I don't think the the party's in a good place.
I don't think the political system's in a good place. Doing a
tearown right now, you're not going to build up something principled
like Teddy Roosevelt's like movement. Okay? You're not going
to do that. Teddy's the bullmoose guy, right? The bullmoose party.
You're not going to build that party right now. That's not what's
happening.
People feel totally over. You're going to get a populist movement.
You're going to get like a crazy populist movement. Okay.
Americans have never Americans have never had a worse stand.
Well, hold on. I actually don't know how true this is. Compared
to like the rest of the world, I feel like Americans have never
had a worse standard of living. Standard of living continues
to rise in other places and America continues to stagnate.
Now, not maybe Europe stagnating even wor even even worse. So,
there might be comparisons there, but compared to like the third
world, it's not close. Now,
that's where you get into globalism versus uh nationalism. And
I don't know what I don't know which side Connor stands on truly.
>> I'm I'm at a I'm at a crossroads. Okay. And by the way,
Bill Crystal arguably one of the people he I think I already
told you what he said, which is basically it's a lost cause.
Go to the Democratic Party. Try to take over the Democratic Party.
>> But here's two options. In my opinion, the Democrat
party is actually probably the easier option, but that's almost
why I think somebody needs to fight for the right. So, get Democrats
to stop being cringe about guns,
possible, not probable, but possible.
And then get Democrats to be a little bit more economically competent
and not to rub elbows with socialists and communists. No offense.
Okay. So, I feel like that's pretty explicit now. Yeah. Connor
wants to push out all of the leftists from the Democrats and
slot in people so the Republicans can take over. Very interesting.
Very neat. I don't know why he's doing that thing where he just
talks about it, right? But whenever I talk to you guys about
this, you guys don't seem to want to give that up.
>> You don't seem to give up the gun control. You don't
seem to want to give up the rubbing elbows. By the way, you want
me to come over so I and people like me to come over to your
side just so I can bolster your voting block enough so you can
beat the I can see I can see what he's doing now. Well, actually,
um, the reason you have to stop rubbing elbows with those people
is cuz [__] is basically Nick Fuentes and if you
can't acknowledge that, then I'll never vote for you. Like, okay,
honestly, Hassan seems a lot more intellectually put together
than you. So, I'm going to go with that. Okay, [__]
you. the other side. It's not because you actually agree with
me on the things that I talk about. It's because you just want
that little bit of electoral edge in order to beat the other
side. Or what's going to happen is Donald Trump hold here's the
other
Like there's there's really only one way to look at it. Either
Connor has like a bunch of like nationalist populist like inkling
uh uh leanings that he's hiding or he's just a Democrat and he
should vote with Democrats anyway. Like either he's got the elements
you don't want and he should [__] off or he should
just vote for Democrats and stop being a whiny [__]
It's like one of the two. It's not it can't be both, right?
It's like you you are starkly you you can't really be in the
middle where you're
>> Donald Trump can't happen. >> And I'm guessing
Oh man, I feel like this is where he's his his answer to Andrew
Wilson is super
uh educational. Okay. when Andrew Wilson is talking about stuff
and Conor's like, "Oh, well, we could argue about whether or
not women should have the vote and you know, I might be on your
side or whatever the fuck." He's like, "I don't really care about
that. It doesn't matter to me if women have the vote." Like,
okay. Like, I think that's pretty instructional on where where
the belief
>> He's going to be a lame duck. And realistically, his
presidency was a disaster
compared to what MAGA was promised, compared to what Donald Trump
has delivered. These are huge gaps in expectation. And so what's
going to happen is in my opinion even within Republicans especially
if he's proven to be in a fee sex trafficking
the Donald Trump label and power broker thing is going to be
extremely damaged and that's going to >> when when it's
Donald Trump we're really worried about those things. We're really
worried about those things which >> power vacuum that power
vacuum is going to be uh filled by the people who have the right
policy the right balls the right funding. >> But that ain't
JD Vance but but that ain't JD Vance. But if you concede it to
JD Vance, he automatically wins. Why would you auto concede?
No, >> I'm not conceding to JD Vance. I don't >> What?
That's not JD Vance. Uh, well, if you concede to JD What? Did
I misunderstand what the question was? >> That ain't JD
Vance.
>> So So none of that is JD Vance. >> But if you
concede to JD Vance, he automatically wins. Why would you?
>> If you concede the Republican party to JD Vance, I mean,
that's probably why Pisco would say you should go fight in the
Republican party despite it being
Yeah, sure. But go fight with those people. Although, you've
lost all credit to fight within your party because you canvas
with Democrats and said you're voting Kamla. >> Auto concede.
>> I'm not conceding to JD Vance. I don't >> to come
over and be a Democrat. >> Wait, wait. No, that's not conceding
JD Vance. That's fighting JD Vance. That's fighting. Happy birthday.
Wait, is is it your birthday, Connor? >> It's my birthday
in a few days. >> Oh, happy almost birthday. I I'm not
conceding to JD Vance. What I'm telling you, I'm just having
with you. party to JD Vance because you're saying that people
like me shouldn't stay in the party and fight him.
>> It's lost,
right?
>> It's lost, >> right? Why? Because some
dude, if I could say the fel, I would. Why? Because some billionaire
New Yorker Democrat used economic populism in order to propagandize
the working class to voting Republican for the first time in
a decade or in decades because some fsler who can barely turn
who can barely say a few sentences above a middle school educational
level. He came in Oh, there's Dude, that's such a dumb attack
on Trump. I'm sorry.
Uh that's one of those things the education level. That's one
of those things where like Trump actually just knows what he's
doing. Unfortunately,
uses very tiny bitty itty bitty words to be very smart. Okay.
>> And he's skinned the party alive. That that's why it's
over. Get the He's He's over because Donald Trump is like
I'm trying to think of who's particularly brutal. Donald Trump's
like Mike Tyson and the Republican party is like a 90-year-old
grandma that got in the boxing ring with him. He beat them so
badly, so quickly that they will never get back up. They are
deceased. That's He's like, "Oh, this fsler who like took over
the party." Yeah, he raped you brutally. We all watched it. We
all watched everybody in your party, every single every single
personnel in your party try to resist him and get brutally.
Okay, that's why he he won. He just totally won.
Yes, you have to deal with that. Yes, you have to deal with that.
You either have to move out or you have to figure out a new idea
that's going to work.
But Jesus Christ, why is he Why is he pretending that this guy
didn't just destroy them completely? Why is he pretending like,
"Oh, this guy's just a loser." No, contend with what he's
>> in some way. >> Dude, like like the entirety of
the United States has dealt with more existential than Donald
Trump for the entirety of its history. >> You're like the
last road bump >> You're like the last
>> What? Wait, what? Hold on. Is that even remotely sane
to say?
What are the bigger road bumps to the United States? What has
been more existent? Like, is it the Civil War? Is that it? Is
it just the literal like we Oh, we're not yet at a real civil
war. So,
okay. So, it's just the Civil War. Okay.
It's a road bump. I mean, I'd say most of US history isn't a
road bump or sorry, most of US history isn't Oh, man. You have
to go back to slavery. You have to go back to the Civil War.
9/11 was worse than Trump. No, it wasn't. No, it wasn't. Not
even close. That's an insane thing to say. Japanese soldier holding
out on one of these like Pacific islands
>> 40 years
40 years after World War II is over and they have to call in
this like decrepit 100-year-old George Bush.
>> That's that's a crazy thing to say. Puggyups, your country
has never been more divided. Your country was at least unified.
Even though people hated Bush, it unified when 9/11 happened.
The social fabric of your country hasn't been harmed like this
since the Civil War. That's absolutely true. We have Trump because
of 911 because of the failures after 911.
I don't think so. You understand that Trump the the the voting
blocks that flipped the places that flipped are not they have
nothing to do with 9/11.
The Iraq war was used as a talking point. It was he was able
to he used it to win the Republican primary. It was not an effective
talking point in the general election.
It was not nothing even remotely close to NAFTA. nothing even
remotely close to the trade stuff. In terms of the states he
had to win to actually win that election, the trade stuff was
what won him the election. That had nothing to do with 911.
I don't know why we're pretending. That's totally politically
illiterate >> In his wheelchair and he can't even speak
anymore and be like, "You're relieved of your duty. Um Connor,
you don't have to be Republican anymore." Like, you are fighting
a war that is >> Bush relieves me of duty. You're right.
When George Bush goes up and he's like, "Hey, man. I tried to
get a few billionaires together in order to back like a neocon
capitalist resurgence within the Republican party. I wasn't able
to find anybody in order to back this project. You are relieved
of duty. That's when I'll hang up the Spurs. When George W. Bush
relieves me of duty.
this is like the only guy in the world. Okay, there's this guy
and the Bullwart guy. The Bullwart guy is even like this anymore.
Are we serious,
guys? The bushes will save us. We have to go back to the Bush
Dynasty, guys. The Bush Dynasty will save us. This is the least
inspiring rhetoric I've ever heard in my entire life,
guys. The Bush Dynasty will save us. What?
Huh?
The guy who brought you such classic hits as the 2008 financial
crisis.
George Bush. Ladies and gentlemen,
>> Bush is a grandpa. George Bush didn't even comment on
the the last elections. The last thing that George Bush has done
like he comments whenever there's like an assassination or something
to be like oh you know me and Laura are really sad about but
he is not engaged in politics and if he tried to it would >> statement
with Obama like three months
>> on like political violence
>> he's memeing
oh you think you think Conor's memeing
you think Connor's you think Conor's
oh boy >> not on like politics
George Bush. >> They're opening libraries. They're going
to funerals. They're >> I don't even I listen I don't even
think George Bush is like an evil person or something. Like I'm
just saying his presidency was not great. I don't Who was Who
did his presidency inspire? What policies did you like from the
Bush
>> They're doing what grandpas do. >> And you know
what grandpas have? Pisco. >> Oh, don't say this. >> Tell
me. Tell me. What do they have? >> Yeah, they are able
to appeal to older people or something. And they have like >> Oh.
They vote. They vote. Tell me. Tell me what they selfishly. >> They
have money. Money. Pensions.
>> They have inheritances
that they want to pass down to the next generation.
>> I can't believe I'm hearing this. >> Do you think
George
This is like totally incoherent. Does Connor think about writing
some stuff down? I I fly by the seat of my pants a lot, too.
But holy [__] You're like going into this conversation
with Pisco. You're just like making up. What are you doing?
Okay, wait. I don't Is this This feels like a bad look. I like
I like debating sometimes on stuff, but I'll say like I'm not
prepared on this. This is Connor talking about like his political
philosophy. Jeb, Barbara,
um I'm trying to think of other people. Do you think Paul Ryan
Do you think any of the Republicans of the past, by the way,
Paul Ryan has disappeared for a decade? Probably because he got
so sick and of the rsler stuff in the Republican party. >> He
has no power. >> He has no power. He He has no power. It
wasn't fun for him to be a Republican. >> You think he
doesn't have millionaire or billionaire friends that are willing
to back younger?
>> Yeah. Hold on. His millionaire Hold on. This is like
the one thing that both parties can agree on is that the neocon
establishment Koch brother funded network is like the worst thing.
Like, sorry, it's not the worst thing. It might not even be the
worst thing. Maybe you could argue the Trump stuff's worse. Okay.
On effect. But in terms of rhetoric, in terms of like what the
At least with Trump, there's like a goal. At least with Trump,
he's like, "Oh, I want to make you guys great again." With with
the Bushes, they're like, "America's the best and oil."
I
What's the message? What's the message?
Like, I guess the message could be, "At least we didn't try to
overthrow the government." Is that Is that where you're coming
from? At least the Koch brothers just collected their bag and
they didn't try to overthrow the government. Really? That's that's
the inspirational message we've got.
They they've abandoned it with his values that they they don't
it doesn't matter. It's over. They they they have to have some
version of Trumpism because the the base just doesn't want this
old style conservative anymore. >> Trumpism do do you know
what Trumpism appeals to that it has fundamentally
That uh they never use the words wealth inequality, but they
talk about wealth inequality all the time. Uh,
okay. Okay. Yes. Yes.
He's so close. Now, what have the Bushes done for wealth inequality?
Connor, pop quiz. What have the Bushes done for wealth inequality
in America? >> Uh, they also talk about rapid demographic
change, both the collapse of the birth rate and mass immigration.
They also talk about existential technological shifts where the
working class of America are being left left behind. And they
they're appealing. >> How? Wait, wait, wait, wait. What?
How? Where? Why? What?
Well, I need to get this now cuz this must have some basis. What
is he talking about when he says he he's reading from something?
Where are they talking about the existential shifts and how are
they fixing them?
I What I You guys are saying chat GPT. I don't know why you'd
say chat GPT instead of just having notes. >> Willing to
and capitalize on the >> Trump is highly supportive of
AI. Yes. How is he going to take the gains of AI and apply them
to the masses to to give that wealth back? How is he not supportive
of AI in the furtherance of increasing the wealth gap?
I've never seen a single policy from Trump on how he is going
to use wealth, how he's going to use AI to increase prosperity
for all Americans.
Never once heard that. Never once seen it. In fact, the crypto
schemes lead me to believe that that doesn't even remotely hit
for him. He doesn't give a >> the dissolution of the social
fabric. >> What's the point that's irrelevant?
to. Sorry. Go ahead. >> What's the point of that irrelevant
ramble? Yeah. Okay. You talked to you talked to PF Young and
you think that this is a genuine concern and they speak to it.
What does that have to do with anything we're talking about?
>> That if you want to seize MAGA's power, you don't have
to become an author. All of the things that you describe about
Trump that make Trump a bad guy are not why he won power. >> I'm
not trying to diagnose why Trump won power. I
We all understand Trump lies. Everybody gets it. Yes. Everybody
gets that Trump lies. Everybody gets that he's totally disingenuous.
Everyone understands that.
The problem is despite the fact that he's caught in lies constantly.
Nobody's willing to do anything about it. That's our problem,
Connor. Okay. He gets caught in the lies constantly. Nobody cares.
Nobody does anything. That's the problem, right? It's the It's
the giant gaping chasm between the policies, the the goals he
purports and the things he actually does. That is the issue with
Donald Trump, obviously.
But now he's created a political system where he can attack and
destroy anybody who's willing to point out any of those deviiances.
Okay. Now he's got some people calling him out and those people
are struggling. Right. Marjorie Taylor Green just left Congress.
You're totally [__] by him and his part him and his
uh like cronies, him and his like Twitter mob. The only people,
by the way, the only people who are speaking truth to power in
terms of that are people that are terrifying.
>> I'm trying to tell you regardless of how he did, he
won and you lost and the war is over and you're not going to
get George W. Bush to save you. >> Do you know why? I don't
care.
What does it matter? >> No, no, no. This is exactly why.
It's because the people in my political block were because of
generational issues. Let's be real. It's probably an aegis thing.
They were asleep at the wheel when these things were happening.
And they said, "Ah, the economy is doing good. Who gives a [__]
The economy is doing good. Who gives a [__] The economy
is doing good. Who gives a [__] Oops, we blew up
the economy.
That's what happened with the people that should have been dealing
with these problems. And it will take philosophical conservatives
and it will take philosophical liberals to address Wait, wait.
The philosophical
>> again.
You don't you don't get that. You get that when you rebuild.
You get that when you we're in the weak men phase or some Okay.
Can we put this? Is there like a can we find a Warhammer 40k
novel that sort of explains people losing their principles? The
like the lack of you know principal discussion happening around
like
civilizational declines. Is there a 40k novel we could reference
so Connor could understand that he's not getting that back? Like
you lost it. You lost it. You don't get it back now. Like you
have to rebuild something entirely new and you need to you need
to be there when when that party collapses. Okay. You need your
own like bull moose party. You need your own like any something
to go and replace it. Okay. >> Conservatives that got us
into this mess in the first place. Who's responsible for this
uh you know wealth inequality and the and the problems with like
uh the economic crisis? I'm going to let me finish this one.
On terms of income inequality, that kind of you can thank Reagan
for that and Reaganism. Uh you saw massive increases in wealth
inequality after after Reagan and yeah and Clinton's policies
that you want uh us to return back to in that respect. I support
the trade deals uh to be clear and I support free trade. Uh I'm
not I'm not talking about that. Um and then also deregulation
which is something else you support deregulation of these uh
financial institutions when it comes to um and uh the pushing
and pushing and pushing of mortgages mortgages mortgages mortgages
mortgages even to people who um couldn't afford them. This is
all problems of the directly on the old class of Republicans
who us for generations and now you want to get you're like, "Oh,
we need to give Bower
Thank you. Finally, Pisco says it. Okay. Yes.
We we need to repeat George Bush classics like the 2008 financial
crisis.
>> Back to these people because they are going to need
to solve wealth inequality. Like it's a
you're misunderstanding. I don't want to give power back to those
people. I want those people to give power to the next generation.
And maybe, by the way, things change. Things obviously. Okay.
So, just as an example, let's just talk about housing because
you mentioned it. >> So, the problem with housing is I'm
pretty sure I would have to look up um it's the guy with the
big nipples. The guy with the big nipples co-wrote a bill in
order to uh make mortgages more >> Big nipples. >> Barney.
Nipples. Barney. Barney.
>> Give me a second. I think it's funny enough to look
up.
with big nipples.
>> He's talking about the >> Trump made fun of him.
>> Nip nipples protruding.
>> Rob North. No.
>> Someone says Barney Frank. You're talking about >> Barney
Frank.
>> Barney Frank. Yes. >> DoddFrank. Act. >> Yeah,
that was Obama.
>> Barney Frank. >> That was someone who nipples
Obama. You know, the president didn't vote for, >> you
know, Obama, you know, the guy that
>> dude, this is this is like I understand why Trump won.
Okay, I said he just tweeted crazy [__] all the time.
God, remember when this was like a really offensive crazy thing
to tweet out?
I do. I remember when this was an insane thing to tweet out.
Jesus. Jesus Christ. >> That you didn't vote for that you
don't like. That's Obama. >> No, no, no, no, no. There
there was a different one. Maybe it wasn't DoddFrank. Um, Frank
Housing Act. I swear to God it was Frank. He does have huge nipples.
Frank Housing Act. The Fair Housing Act of 68. I I don't know
who gives a Well, let's stop talking about DoddFrank's nipp or
Mr. Frank's nipples. Okay.
>> The the broader point is, okay, these are these are
>> housing real quick. All right. Go talk about housing.
>> I'll try to be super brief about it. >> What happened
was housing was unfair. And so what they did is they secured
the mortgages, they made them federally backed, and they also
made them more accessible to working-class people. This caused
a housing boom where we were building shitloads of housing through
the 2000s. And this was a large part of the economy, and people
were making money handoverfist. But because it was so deregulated,
they were making risky loans to plenty of people who had no business
getting those loans. You could go ahead and watch the whatever
that movie is, uh, The Big Short, in order to see how it how
it went. But effectively what ended up happening was after this
time period we collapsed the entire market through 2008. It was
the worst financial disaster besides CO and besides the great
depression. >> Uh I think wait was it a worse financial
disaster than CO
for the US only?
Maybe. Oh man with CO there are a lot of confounding factors.
I feel like CO by itself wasn't actually that big deal. There
were there were economic changes coming that get confounded in
there and then it looks like CO's worse. and then we stopped
building houses and the financial incentives that were there
because of the reckless incentivization of building houses has
remained stagnant for the past 20 years. So yes, we have a problem
with demography, we have a problem with population, we have a
problem with affordability, but one of the problems that you
solve pricing with is supply. So what arguably we need to do,
I hate to say this, is we need to implode the American economy
again through excess housing supply. And the federal government
has the capacity to do that. So I would almost argue, hey guys,
did you enjoy the 2000s to 2008 housing bubble? We're doing it
again because we're going to make it so average workingass Americans
can afford houses. And then I would straight up repeat
uh the the financial incentives in order to get into a house.
Maybe a little bit smarter this time.
Bro, why why the with every single government on planet Earth
discussing um like building houses and how they create increase
like housing costs or how they decrease housing costs? How in
the [__] is lumber not like skyrocketing like lumber
futures? You'd expect this. No,
wouldn't you expect this to just pop the [__] off?
Kind of weird to me. Anyway,
um okay. I mean, you recognize that the
the mortgage crisis
um was attendant to rising prices in homes, right? And
overvaluation of of homes and >> Yeah, but we would focus
on supply. >> Okay. And you want So, you want to build
>> demand outstrips supply. That doesn't mean there wasn't
a substantial >> Oh, sure, sure, sure, sure. I see what
you're saying that it's not going to be a housing boom based
on single family homes. It'll be a housing boom based on like
apartment building, large scale um highdensity housing. >> Me
too. I want to build more too. Great. I want to build I don't
know what the [__] this has to do with fighting a
lost war. Number one, >> we don't have to be as dumb as
>> Dude, I love that Pisco and Connor started talking once
a week and Pisco is already at the point where he can see the
pattern of Connor just starts talking about totally irrelevant
[__] in the middle of like contended points. Like
we have a disagreement and Connor will go off on a tangent. He
will get totally lost and have a sundowning moment and just start
talking about something random and disjoint, disconnected. Like,
can you just stick to the conversation, dude? >> Previous
generation. We can make >> We're about to hear about the
eighth different career that Connor had. We're like, we're like
one more total on an individual point away from Connor telling
us about the time he was like actually a firefighter for 6 months,
like a volunteer firefighter. I swear to >> mistakes.
brand new stupid mistakes that are as glorious and as the old
ones, but we don't have to make the same mistakes.
I don't even think we're having a conversation right now, Connor.
I I don't feel that >> you're talking about the same thing.
>> You said you said it's lost. Quit. And I'm saying, you
know, that's what's >> I I think you need to be realistic
about the prospects of >> The ironic thing is is Connor
keeps saying that he won't vote for one person or another based
on he like Wait, he wags his finger. Okay. Okay. He says, "I'm
not going to vote for these people. I'm not going to vote for
these people or whatever the right."
And he he's like waging fingers at Pisco and and Democrats and
stuff. How is that any different from Hassan in terms of US electoralism?
Like Hassan's like, "Hey, these are my these are my needs to
vote for somebody." And Connor just said the same thing. Yeah.
If you're not going to if you're going to vote against guns,
if you're going to vote for gun control, I won't vote for you.
And Hassan says, "If you're going to vote to keep people to keep
sending weapons over to Gaza, I'm not going to vote for you."
feels like one of those is more noble a principle than the other.
Although I guess in the US you could argue defending the Second
Amendment is a noble principle, too. But I don't know. It's like
why is that different? Why is that so much worse when it comes
from >> A JD Vance presidency or a uh like in what way
does a JD Vance presidency empower the people you want to empower?
In what sense?
Uh, well, I mean, number one, it probably depends on what they're
deregulating or whatever, but I actually I I am way less cynical
about like technofuturism,
technofudalism. I'm way less cynical about that than you are.
>> you said why?
What capacity for humanity have any of these people demonstrated?
What capacity for leadership? What capacity for
admiraability have any of these people
Wait, what? what capacity for any positive human trait of any
of these people shown. Elon Musk just Elon Musk just straight
up buys companies and puts his name on them and he does not the
only thing he provides is marketing. You're you're literally
putting
you're putting your future in the hands of a used car salesman.
Okay? Just the best used car salesman ever. Now, maybe if you
just need buyin from investors to put money into this one thing
or you need to build the working populace out of some money,
maybe Elon's your guy. But I would assume if you're listen, if
Connor is 40k pled, like I would think, shouldn't he be going
for like people who have noble traits? Shouldn't he be like looking
for nobility in people like
Is Shouldn't we Should we be looking for the best used car salesman
to lead humanity? Is that what 40k is about? the guy who can
be like, "Guys, we're going to take over like 80 planets." And
then they take over like half of a planet and he's like, "Huge
success, guys. We won. We totally won. Thank you for giving me
your money. That's what we want." >> These are like crab
people. >> These are crab. >> Okay, Porttoella, you
need to you need to chill with the You really wasted your rename
on that? I need you to to stop. Okay? I need you to stop doing
crazy [__] These are crap people. They want to turn
parts of the country into their tech foms.
ideology is like
>> I'll I think they'll probably create insane in insane
technologies that will revolutionize humanity. Do do you understand?
Hold on real quick. Ju just as an example,
>> dude. I
we're it's over. It's so over. It's so completely and utterly
over.
What What technologies have they created? What technologies have
these people who are going to take over created? These people
are money managers. These people are
How many of these people are founders?
What part of Facebook revolutionized humanity? I'm sorry. Facebook,
while it is a a fantastic profit-seeking entity, it has been
great to make money for certain people. What has it advanced
humanity in terms of humanity? Where have we gone because of
Facebook?
Now, Elon's probably your best bet here with SpaceX, but Elon
isn't the engineer. He's barely These companies have these goals
before he comes around. Oh, man. I have to I have to keep listening,
but Jesus Christ.
It's just like the printing press. It is not. It is not. It is
not. It is not. Social the social media people are the people
who figure out how to tap into your dopamine to milk you, to
turn you into a cow so they could milk you for all of your money
in terms of getting advertising revenue for your time. That's
all they figured out. They figured out how to make you worthless.
They figured out how to devalue your labor, how to make you one
of the least desirable job markets in the world. That's what
they did. Okay? Because you have this thing to and liberals in
general, no offense, um you have this thing where you guys just
act confidently correct that everybody but you is a massive piece
of incapable of doing anything right. Do you understand Starship?
Do you understand like what Starship does? Can you tell me what
Starship does briefly? >> I don't even know what Starship
is,
>> dude. I almost would agree that Elon is capable of summoning
capital to do projects. Okay. Elon Musk alone. All right. All
the other tech billionaires. No. Peter Teal, no. Peter Teal is
not even somebody who invents. PETER TEAL IS JUST A GUY WHO THROWS
MONEY in things. He is just a good he has a good eye for what
is a good product and will like have the the [__]
cattle like flock to it. Okay. That's what Peter Teal does. He
he is a very very good forecaster of company's futures.
All right.
Now, Elon, maybe a little bit more. Starlink's awesome. Love
Starlink. I don't know what the Starship is. I'm guessing Connor's
going to explain it. Okay. It seems like all of Elon's nonprofit
seeeking things, okay, things that don't make him a ton of money,
they don't actually really pan out in the end. I'm trying to
think of something that isn't a huge profit- seeeking thing that
hasn't make him made him tons of money. Where does that pan out
or where does that worked?
Starship is the rocket to Mars. Okay. Does it exist? Does it
work? Okay. >> I don't know what you're talking about.
>> That's kind of my point. So Starship is Elon Musk creation.
It's a heavy lift repeatable vehicle. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
And it's like blowing up, right?
>> No. And they and they >> I would say the rockets
that SpaceX made the reusable rockets being able to land the
rocket to have it that was probably the biggest thing that they
now
I would say
with with the rockets with the reusable like rockets that don't
burn up. Okay.
I would say if those are successful, if those are if those are
like good, that's one of the most profitable technologies because
of how you know satellite deployments are increasing exponentially,
right? That's that's an incredibly useful thing. That's an incredibly
helpful thing. It's very very good to not just be shooting rockets
into space and letting them orbit around like space trash. Okay,
that's that's good stuff.
But that's basically that's like the and by the way that drives
profit-seeking ventures. profit seeeking ventures that Elon Musk
uses um and basically just like follows his own rules.
There's a whole story about with with SpaceX where like he basically
changed the orbit of SpaceX satellites contrary to what he had
agreed to with the government, the US government, and basically
just nobody could call him on it. Nobody could be like, "Oh,
that's you can't do that." They funded it for like a ton of money
and they're like constantly behind schedule and not meeting their
their marks, right? Well, number one, that's like the history
of NASA. So being expensive and being behind budget is not like
>> it's also the history of Elon Musk like straight up
lying Hyperloop and the Boring Company and we're going to have
self-driving cars. Don't worry guys, it'll pay for itself. >> I
want to ask you again. Do you do you know what uh Starship's
technical capacity is? >> I don't have any specific technical
expertise to tell you what Starship is. I think it's like a >> Okay,
hold on. Listen. The Falcon rocket or whatever. Very cool. All
right. Unfortunately, there are a bunch of other Elon M projects
that are not like that that do actually just they are just dead
on arrival. They never go anywhere. Okay. When when was the forecasted
date for fully self-driving cars?
And is it even is it even agreed upon yet that that's possible
given the technology for Teslas?
Right. He he runs on dreams and he says that it's going to happen
with no real understanding of whether or not it can be done.
That's who Elon is. And in some of the cases, the technical team
around him can do it. But in a lot of cases, he's just he's just
running with it regardless of whether it can be done or
Like Steve Jobs before him, he's just going to say that it will
work. He's going to say they can do it even though even when
they tell him no. And then if they don't pull a miracle out of
the hat, if he doesn't like put them in a crazy position, his
his engineering team, and they don't pull a miracle out of the
hat, then he doesn't deliver cuz he has no idea what he's talking
about >> the reusable. The whole notion, right, it's like
a reusable thing. That's the most I know about it. >> Okay.
It can uh I would have to make sure. As a matter of fact, is
it 300,000?
I think it's 300,000. >> You just want to play 40k. You
just want it to be like 40k and you want to create 40k. But >> that's
very funny that Pisco just comes out and says it.
>> Uh now Pisco,
how should I describe this?
I don't think You know what? It's good. I'm just going to say
it's good. >> You forget that 40k is like the worst of
all possible. Yeah. 40k is a dystopia. No, no, no, no. What's
the What's the gay [__] farming game that all the
lefties play? >> Don't use gay in the pajorative. You do
this a lot. >> No, it actually might be a game. Uh what
what what's the um what's what's the game where like you you
farm and
No, he's talking about uh
Harvest Moon or whatever. Not Harvest Moon. What is it called?
The the Switch game. Farmville.
Oh, Stardew. No, he's probably talking about Stardew. I said
Harvest Moon cuz I'm a boomer. Okay. Animal Crossing was what
I was thinking of, but he is probably talking about Star. That's
an old one.
>> Your chat knows
that game. >> So, so what the My >> Who gives a [__]
about Starship,
>> dude. The funny thing is I've literally never played
Harvest Moon. I said Harvest Moon. I've never played that game.
That game was way too complex, I think, when I when I was young.
like when it actually I remember seeing it in the in like a Blockbuster
or something and I remember thinking about getting it and then
I looked in the back. I'm like, "Oh, that's like too much." No,
no, no, thank you. >> Uh well, give me a second and I'll
tell you why. What is Starship's lift capacity? It's either 30
I don't want to say like 30,000 tons because I I think that's
crazy. Oh, 150 metric tons. Okay, so I think it's 300,000 lb
slight or 150 metric tons.
And effectively what that means is you can move 300,000 lb of
gear across the planet in 90 minutes.
Okay. It went from Tampa to the Indian Ocean off the coast of
India in 90 minutes. It travels 17,000 km an hour. >> Yeah.
And how much did it cost and how much fuel did he use?
>> No idea.
>> Not good questions to be honest. Just the it's possible
that the idea is like cool and and should be thought about and
and used, right?
I will say SpaceX seems to be managed quite well. >> But
at the same time, if you're talking about military technology,
military capacity, if you're talking about like the lasers coming
online in reference to the United States, in reference to a battleship,
in reference to the C130, there are tons of technologies that
are going to be like so important to the future of the human
race. And I understand like we should take care of our people.
We don't disagree on that. People should have food, water, shelter,
or it should be extremely cheap and available. We don't disagree
on that. But you're kind of like casting out the entire like
tech bro project because you don't like them on a personal level.
And I think that's silly. I think that's silly as >> I
I am not. We need to have in many respects. I'm abundance build.
I think we need new inventions.
>> Um the 300,000. No, no, no, no. It's uh 100 to 150 metric
tonses is what it's supposed to be able to carry in expendable
mode. Not recovering the ship/ booster. Elon says it can have
a payload of 250 to 300 metric tons.
And that's sending it into orbit. So wait, is this the right
thing? The Starship, is he saying going anywhere on Earth?
Is this the the correct thing? Like it's supposed to go Are they
dropping this stuff? Is it like it goes into low Earth orbit
and then it like drops the stuff in a way that it'll drop back
down to the ground?
Is it doing like air drops from the from like the stratosphere?
I don't even know what I don't know what's going on. >> I
think we need to be funny. That's why, by the way, >> and
more infrastructure, right? We need to build the cities of the
future and the trains of the future and all that >> that
requires government to work it. >> It also and by the way
abundance libs want deregulation in reference to like city infrastructure
projects and and state infrastructure projects. >> The
the smart abundance libs are very tailored about which areas
that they want um you know quicker uh checks and and less environmental
reviews and that kind of stuff. And and even then like we I think
we have to be more tailored and and thoughtful and smart. So
no doubt we need more inventions. We need to build more stuff.
All that stuff is absolutely true. But that requires government
to function, government to work. JD Vance is trying to destroy
government. These tech feudalists, they don't give a [__]
about you. They don't give a [__] about any of this
stuff. And before we start working about Starship, why don't
we worry about the housing and energy crisis in the country now
before we start spending $100 billion to move whatever thing
you said from one place to another. How how about we get our
like our infrastructure to to be effective with the technologies
we currently have as opposed to u you know putting all our eggs
in in this basket
and again when there >> I don't I don't necessarily like
like this response from Pisco I think he's probably correct in
some ways but I don't like the response of like oh well we have
problems here so we shouldn't do any of this right I don't I
don't like that I think profit- seeeking entities should be able
to do that stuff right I think that's probably not a problem.
I just don't think those people are necessarily responsible.
I don't trust those people to be like feudal lords. That's all
I'm talking about. Like, no, I I trust the I could trust Elon
Musk to do the fundraising for Star or SpaceX. Okay? I can trust
him to do that to do the marketing and the fundraising for SpaceX.
I don't trust him with anything else. Okay?
People hear Elon Musk's voice and they are enchanted by it. All
right? I care about Mars more than the poor. Yeah, this is the
kind of thing that I would expect most people say. you're probably
not going to Mars either way. Elon has no idea if he's going
to Mars. He just talks about it because it's a good way for him
to drive like um hiring and drive, you know, funding for his
>> There's so much potential danger in
elevating someone like JD Vance
for the sole purpose of, I guess, your technological ambitions
on this assumption that it's going to lead to more technology.
Remember what JD Vance is helping oversee? He's helping oversee
Doge cuts and massive cuts to research in this country. He's
overseeing these tariffs which are degrowth which are horrible.
He's ideologically in favor of these kinds of tariffs. Um so
he is not a good economic steward. I the real talking points
on JD Vance should be that he is not actually principally in
favor of anything except enriching himself and gaining power.
That should be the conversation around JD Vance. You shouldn't
say oh principally he's committed to like these. No he's not.
He's not principally committed to that guy will morph in a second.
If Assam [__] takes over the planet, it'll be with
JD Vance as vice president. And Connor should reckon with this
when he decides that he's going to support JD Vance or he thinks
JD Vance JD Vance might be his guy in some way that he has no
principles worth um talking about when it comes to rule of law
and constitution. And because you're like, "Ooh, shiny starship
Elon Musk. I can't believe you're an Elon Musk laser." Really?
I don't like Elon Musk as a person. I think he's terrible. As
a matter of fact, I think one of the things that's terrible about
him is the fact that he's willing to work with a after finding
out he's a but anyways uh >> and Vance and Vance isn't.
It's just like you maybe just pick a different guy, Connor.
Don't don't be like, "Oh, JD Vance, listen, we could help JD
Vance steer the party in a good direction with the technof the
techno overlords. They'll help us guys. We'll have cool technologies."
No, we won't.
These people these people, I guarantee you at least two of those.
Look at Mark Andre's face and tell me that guy isn't envisioning
like a harm of 500 cloned versions of
like 13-year-old Natalie Portman from the Leon the Professional.
Okay, that's like what that's what Mark Andre is driving towards.
Okay, that's what he wants. That's what he wants. That's what
he's doing this all for. Okay, they're going to try to take over
the world so they can do crazy.
I I don't I don't trust any of those people. All right. >> No,
Vance is the I think that they're both like indictable characters.
But at the same time, if Elon Musk builds a starship that can
travel 17,000 km an hour, cross the globe within 90 minutes,
and carry 150 metric tons, that's worth some level of respect.
And by the way, you're going to need people like that for the
project. >> He was saying 300,000 tons or something before.
300 300,000 tons or something. It's crazy. >> Let's talk
about Gavin. >> It's It's so funny that he literally has
no idea what any of it means at all. Okay. He He doesn't even
know. He's just like He literally is just like, "Oh, shiny spaceship."
Just like my Warhammer. He That's unironically his position.
He went from 150 tons to 300,000 tons to 150 tons in like a
That's nuts. >> Newsome real quick. Okay. Gavin Newsome.
I'm happy he's abundance build. Okay. And if he shuts the up
about guns and he's abundance pill and that's what he hits on,
then I'll probably vote for him over JD Vance. But it depends
on what the left wing is doing. As an example, I am deeply [__]
uncomfortable with the level to which um you hutch ball Oh,
here it comes. Here it comes. Wait, I actually have to I'm going
to pull it back like a little bit here. You guys are going to
rewatch this cuz I have to get some caffeine real quick. Okay,
but I'm I'm ready. We're ready. Here it is. Here it is. This
is what we've all been This is what we've been watching for.
Okay, I'm going to use the bathroom. I'm going to get some caffeine.
There's so much potential danger in
elevating someone like JD Vance
for the sole purpose of I guess your technological ambitions
on this assumption that it's going to lead to more technology.
Remember what JD Vance is helping oversee? He's helping oversee
Doge cuts and massive cuts to research in this country. He's
overseeing these tariffs which are degrowth which are horrible.
He's ideologically in favor of these kinds of tariffs. Um, so
he is not a good economic steward. He has no principles worth
um talking about when it comes to rule of law and constitution.
And because you're like, "Ooh, shiny starship. Elon Musk, I can't
believe you're an Elon Musk laser." Really? Uh, I don't like
Elon Musk as a person. I think he's terrible. As a matter of
fact, I think one of the things that's terrible about him is
the fact that he's willing to work with a after finding out he's
a >> Oh, it's really good that we went back, by the way.
It's really good that we went back and saw where this started.
Okay. Because a little while ago, Connor was basically arguing
like, "Oh, we need to get back to Republicanism like like Teddy
Roosevelt." And you know what? I'd elevate JD Vance. We get some
cool technologies. Bro, Teddy Roosevelt would JD Vance in the
stomach and let him bleed out in his in a vat of his own acid,
eating his inner organs. Okay.
Teddy Roosevelt would kill that immediately. Not advocating for
JD Vance. We wouldn't do it. I'm just saying Teddy Roosevelt
would. Okay?
Like
Teddy Roosevelt would hate JD Vance.
Teddy Roosevelt's the guy who like persevered in his own acid.
Yeah. His stomach acid would eat his inner organs. Okay. Every
single one of his his his stomach would start bleeding into his
uh his his like stomach would get perforated. It would start
bleeding into his torso. Okay? And he would go septic and he
would die over a period of days in agony. Okay? That's what Teddy
Roosevelt would want for JD Vance.
No. None of us though. None of us would want that. And we don't
want JD Vance hurt in any way. But Teddy Roosevelt, that guy
was psychotic. Okay. Okay. Anyway, what are you talking about?
Brandon Buckingham again. Anyway, so
just that was the ideological starting point was was Teddy Roosevelt.
And now we've gotten to well JD Vance could maybe get us some
technology. That would be cool. Like more crypto deregula. Don't
we need more crypto deregulation, guys? But anyways, uh, >> and
Vance and Vance isn't.
>> No, Vance is the same. I think that they're both like
indictable characters, but at the same time, >> Oh, so
they're they're the same. So, realistically, you just have no
problem with
like I'm glad that Connor has outed himself. He's like, "Guys,
I think Elon Musk is a terrible person cuz he works with a
No. Uh, actually JD is still working with a What are you supposed
to do? Not work with the I don't Dude, that's what you got to
do. work with. >> If Elon Musk builds a starship that can
travel 17,000 km an hour, cross the globe within 90 minutes,
and carry 150 metric tons, that's worth some level of
>> guys. We can get we can get 400 14year-olds to an island
anywhere in the Pacific in 90 minutes.
You have no idea the kind of we're working on. >> And by
the way, you're going to need people like that for the project.
And let's talk about Gavin Newsome real quick. Okay, Gavin Newsome.
I'm happy he's abundance build. Okay. And if he shuts the up
about guns and he's abundance pill and that's what he hits on,
then I'll probably vote for him over JD Vance. But it depends
on what the left wing is doing. As an example, I am deeply uncomfortable
with the level to which um you
now all of these all of this acceptance of course. Okay. I hate
to I hate to hand Hassan a W again, but all of this acceptance
and he's like, "But you guys, I'd maybe look at you guys if you
stopped to hang out with Assan." Clearly, anybody who is tolerant
of anybody who is a just hates Assad and they hate the aura that
he exudes. Okay, Connor just can't really describe it. He can't
ever logically make it make sense, but he can say it over and
over again. Hassan is bad. Hassan is bad. Hassan is >> You
hutch ball. uh the bull work, Tim Miller, um Kla Harris, uh all
these I am uncomfortable to which to the point that you guys
are willing to either glaze, socialize, normalize
socialists, decommodification of basic human needs and workers
owning the means of production. I don't give a [__]
if they're democratic.
They are anti- capitalist pieces of [__] And so the
fact that you guys are like, "We need to build a coalition between
Connor, the science fiction guy, who likes the free market, but
he also likes individual freedom, freedom of consciousness in
the Constitution of the United States, but we also need him to
be okay with a [__] socialist, it's not going to
happen." And if you run a socialist or if you run somebody who's
pandering to socialists, it's not going to [__] happen.
I like electorally
I will let a thousand children be says Connor. Okay. I'll let
a thousand kids be before I vote for a socialist or anybody who
associates with one. Cool. That's a really interesting set of
priorities, Connor. I can see definitely we should get the Republican
party back. We need the We need the old Republican party. Uh
I think I don't know. I think I what?
I want to punish you for that action the same way that I electorally
PUNISH >> WAY MORE THAN I'LL PUNISH ANYBODY who associates
with the right for normalizing Christian nationalists. >> Pisco
has to be so out on the island right now. Holy
how we going to this pig? This is maybe the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my life. Contradictions abound. He files. Oh, trust
me. We're going to need that chart that Connor drew, okay? On
development cuz that's going to be critical in his defense of
himself coming up, okay? >> I mean that literally. Don't
go look for the chart. >> These guys, man,
>> he's holding
all of the things that I just said out loud. Okay? Every single
thing I just said out loud is something Pisco is thinking and
being like, "I can't do that. I can't say that. I can't say
God, how do I even how do I even respond here? I need to I I
feel like I need to point out all of those things, but I >> I
want you to understand I view Hassan [__] and Nick
Fuentes as the same guy. >> There it is. I view Hassan
Pike from Nick Fentes as the same guy.
This is H. This is essentially just saying socialism is the worst
thing on
right? Like like literally worse than it's worse than anything
else.
Actual feudalism. actual like actual technofudalism,
a a future where nobody has liberty, nobody has anything. They're
just they're just total surfs under, you know, some some warlord
who has a bunch of like drones that can kill, right? Like a bunch
of military drones from Palmer Lucky living in a compound. Uh
they they take the right of first night with all of the people
who get married, right? That that's the world Connor wants over
Hassan
being associated with a candidate.
>> I view them as the same guy on opposite sides of the
spectrum. That's genuinely how I view these people.
>> Okay. Do you view Mom Donnie the same as Nick Quentes?
>> Uh, I view Mom Donnie as Hassan [__] in
the closet.
>> So, the answer is yes. Therefore, >> no, it's
not. Yes. This is the clip I watched. Connor sees him as more
of a different kind of different different >> No, he has
the shame to be in the closet. I view M Donnie as JD Vance. help
me out there because you're willing to vote for JD Vance but
not mom Donnie >> because JD Vance doesn't come out and
say I hate
is that the line? JD Vance doesn't come out and say I hate I
don't think Mumani says that.
Wait, where does Mum Donnie say that?
In fact, where does anybody on the left say that? Could you tell
me? That's very interesting. There's only one person and people
who associate with him who has come out and said anything close
to I hate you. >> As a matter of fact, he's probably like
a zio shell. Um, and he's also not a racist. He may or he's not
like a he might be an anti-lack racist, but he's not an anti-Indian
racist. We know.
>> Uh, I wouldn't even give him that. His wife is like
three or four points above him on a 10-point scale of
That will undo a lot of racism very quickly. Okay. That um yeah,
like I I view JD Vance as a
um number one, I'll go back to the fact that I think he's a political
opportunist uh opportunist, but to the degree that he is like
a post-liberal liberal and anti-liberal like because he said
that before in like uh briefings and um to the degree that he's
a post-liberal um I think that he is infinitely more tepid than
Curtis Yarvin or Nick Fentes. He He is a >> He just doesn't
have beliefs. That's the That's the thing. He literally doesn't
have beliefs, Connor. He has no trackable principles. Like, there's
nothing there. The the the persona he came into politics with
was not his. And the persona he shifted to after he realized
the first persona didn't work is also not his. We don't know
who JD Vance is. We know nothing about this person. We know only
the curated image that anybody has ever seen. Okay? None of us
know who he really is. He is just a made person. He is not the
the thing that you see. Okay. It's like the opening of American
Psycho. All right. You don't see me. It's like a mask. It's that
whole rant is just JD Vance. >> He is a tepid palatable
version of an extremist ideology. I think mom Donnie
>> JD Vance will swing to whatever ideology he thinks will
get him in power. He will he will maintain all positions. He
will try to to bend in any way he can. Okay? I'm telling you,
JD Vance would vote for Mani. JD Vance would work with Mdani.
JD Vance would suck Mumani's if it got Peter Teal $500 million.
Okay. He would he would do it immediately. >> Is a tepid,
palatable version of an extremist ideology.
>> Of someone like Fuentes. >> Yeah. Fuentes is the
extreme version. Hassan [__] is the extreme version.
>> Mamani
is Muslim.
>> What does that have to do with anything?
>> Well, that seems to be pretty counter to Christian nationalism.
Mamdani is progay.
Mamdani is
not anti-Semitic.
You think he is? >> Yeah, I would say that. >> Yeah.
The Hold on. The not anti-Semitic was the critical thing because
why the question was why would you vote for Zoron or sorry, why
would you vote for JD Vance over Zoron? You wouldn't vote for
Zoron. You would vote for JD Vance. Well, uh, he's not anti-Semitic.
What the does that even mean? >> I I think that J I think
that's like populist opportunism.
And also, Hassan [__] is all those things. What about
it? I never want to hear
>> Hassan [__] is all of those things. So,
he's anti Wait, anti Oh, wait. Did he just say Hassan Piker's
not anti pretty counter to Christian?
>> How do you HOW DO YOU BEND YOURSELF INTO THIS position
then? What?
HOW DOES DUDE, THIS IS so internally contradictory? What are
you doing?
He he just he just said, "Okay, yeah, Hassan Piker's also all
of those things." He I thought the whole predicate for this was,
"Oh, well, at least JD isn't anti-Semitic in the JD versus Zoron
comparison." And then he says he agrees Zoron's not anti-Semitic
and says Hassan is also not. He must have misunderstood. That's
the only explanation here, right? >> Muslim Mani is progay.
Mamani is
not
>> You think he is? Yeah, I would say that I I think that
J I think that's like populist opportunism and also Hassan [__]
is all those things. What about >> I never want to hear
another thing about anti-semitism from people who take the position
that you just did. I never want to hear
>> Hassan [__] is like an anti-semite. Hassan
the left is really anti-semitic,
>> Uh, okay. I guess Connor's just totally folded on like
everything he's been arguing for. I don't I I literally Dude,
this is one of those moments. Oh, what the [__] is
it?
Dude, I my whole brain is like wrinkled now. I or smooth. I don't
even know. Connor has done like concussive damage to my brain
with his opinion somehow. >> Another word about anti-semitism
from people who are going to make a comparison as between Fuentes
who is talking about the problems of world
and how it's not an Israel problem.
But hold on. Also,
I and listen, I'm not I'm not trying to talk Nick here cuz I
know I know I'm not trying to talk Nick, okay? But every single
thing that Connor dislikes about
Hassan. Nick is worse. Nick is way
Like you talk about America bad, okay, and and not supporting
a unipolar world order. That is one of Conor's chief complaints
about Hassan. Nick Fentes is the guy who just had a rant recently
about how well I guess guys I guess the American Empire won.
I know he I know he started talking about No, no, no, no, no,
no, no. Nick doesn't support a UI world order. He doesn't. He
hasn't for a long time. He's been talking about how he thinks
like Russia could be winning. He He's been talking about how
Russia's maybe not the bad guy in certain situations. He's been
He's been that guy. He literally just talked about how guys I
guess the American Empire won. I I didn't think it was going
to happen. I didn't think they would. I thought there was all
going to come apart at the
Like anything you could accuse Assan of in terms of supporting
Russia versus Ukraine, Fentes is 10 times more guilty of. What
the [__] >> problem? And you know to the extent
that they support Israel, they should be sent out of the country.
And um >> comparing basically are you >> comparing
to mom Dani
>> or Hassan Hassan said something even 1% of that
>> u Hassan was denying the rap on October 7, 2023 and
saying that there's no evidence for them despite reading a UN
report that says that
>> okay I I'm sorry.
So you the point on which you are going to vote for or or support
JD Vance Fuentes over
is anti-semitism
is October 7th atrocity denial. These are the lines by which
you're dividing these two groups. But you're saying Hassan and
Zoron are worse than JD Vance and Nick Fuentes.
Really? That's the that's the direct that's stack we're going
to take. >> We have like eyewitness testimony. We have
victim testimony. We have like we have like uh the autopsies
of people who were shot in the back of the head and had their
genitals burned. And we found a bunch of women tied to various
like uh stop signs in trees with their panties pulled down under
their legs and their arms tied around these objects. And he was
like, "Oh yeah, but they didn't get semen samples." So the didn't
happen. >> Okay. People who say that it like that you would
Okay. So that is the biggest problem he has with Hassan Pikers
that Hassan said uh I don't think that happened or we don't have
an example of that in captivity, right? I think that was it.
But I don't think, correct me if I'm wrong, that that we don't
have an example in captivity. He wasn't denying the actual atrocities
from the war. I thought he's saying they didn't capture people,
take them back to Gaza, and then rape them, which is also like
not true. But I think that was his point. No, if I'm remembering
the clip correctly, >> this quote because I've heard this
>> Unfortunately, he has Unfortunately, he has the other
clip of like somebody asked about and he goes, "What did Husba
do?" Dude, what did he's got that clip which is >> like
the direct and circumstantial evidence point which are really
>> He laughed every time came up. Bro, I talk about I use
here as a punchline all the time. You You can't possibly virtue
signal on this. >> Really stupid points. There is direct
evidence. Uh indirect evidence is only just like testimony of
it. And there >> Yeah. I I also think this is the point
that like it Well, no, no, no, hold on. He had another point
as well. This would be his new point like where he's standing
now that systematic in terms of a direct top down control. Hey,
you guys should go out and to to enforce these things. I think
that would be his new >> There are people who who testify
to that effect. Um but I don't understand. So, so because he
takes this view that um these are the the notion of
mass as a tool of war or something that that's the claim, right?
That this is like as um mass rape event something like that,
right? That this was a coordinated uh >> systematic rape
I think is the mass systemic rape >> attempted valitional.
>> Yeah. He want he wants to say it's
>> Well, hang on a second. So, you're saying that his view
on that, which I don't I don't know what he said and I'm I'm
I'm not here to defend.
>> You can grant it. You can grant that that's his position.
And then apparently that is what makes Hassan too anti-Semitic
to consider voting for to consider voting for somebody who would
even support him or sorry be supported by him, who would associate
with him.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. Poor Bellar, you got
you came in a little after me, but yes. If you if you grant all
of that, you're still saying something totally insane, something
totally disconnected from reality. Well, Nick Fentes and Hassan
are basically the same. Yeah, Hassan has this position where
he thinks that probably people were raped on October 7th, but
it wasn't like the commander said, "You need to rape as many
women as you can." That's like that's Hassan's version of anti-semitism
and Nick Fentes is like the Jews are taking over the planet.
We need to have a spiritual war against them every
I What are we doing? What are we doing?
This is your brain on Dude, I This is almost as it's getting
close. It might be No, you know what? It's more It's more than
the Well, actually, Juice would be better off with Byron Gains
than Hassan [__]
That's where we've gotten to. Okay, it's actually worse than
that. Maybe. I don't know. I have to think about it. And people
who who do these are some of the dumbest, most spitebased opinions
I've ever heard in my entire life. They are embarrassing. Why
would you take anybody's opinion seriously on this? >> This
kind of quibbling about >> like this is disqualifying to
provide political opinion on the internet. Totally disqualifying.
You should off
politics. You can't be objective in any remote way. Like just
off, okay? Direct circumstantial evidence. And I would need to
have the the video proof of of this or that, which by the by
the way, I would consider to be circumstantial. I I basically
think anything that isn't like witness direct witness testimony
is is >> Okay, get through the autism pisco.
Actually, technically anecdotal ane
are anecdotal. Technically, they're they're circumstantial evidence.
Like there are anecdotal. I didn't get them right. Uh are circumstantial
evidence actually. Who cares, bro? Just grant him the position
and talk about how insane he is. Um people people will say things
like
only direct evidence matters when some of the strongest evidence
DNA is circumstantial evidence. It's not direct evidence. It's
circumstantial evidence. So all that [__] is [__]
stupid. But you're comparing that view which has to do with like
have they proved to your satisfaction or to Hassan satisfaction
the existence of mass coordinated rap as an intentional uh tool
and strategy on October. I want listen if we talk to these people
ever if we talk to Connor or anything
maybe maybe we will but
my question would be like to have this position you absolutely
would have to have the position that the Holocaust is not a unique
genocide and not a unique moment in human history
right you you would have to have that position no which I don't
know if Connor knows this but that's considered pretty pretty
anti-semitic by the Zionist lobby
that's the Holocaust was not special is the position you have
to have here to think that oh on the basis of the ideology alone
you are like evil
because then you argue that the great leap forward is a genocide
that is like totally cataclysmic and right like that's that's
not something you're allowed to say 7th and you're saying that
is comparable in terms of its anti-semitism to Nick Fuentes's
explicit anti-semitism
regarding world
>> even uh we could even shift it away from anti-semitism
because I don't even know.
>> You should you should try to shift it away from anti-semitism
because I think one I think that's the only thing he's going
to have to just go Hassan believes in the same thing Mao did.
Okay, he believes Ma was good. Hassan believes Ma was good. That's
the same as Fentes believing Hitler was good and he doesn't think
the genocide is disqualifying. He thinks the ideology should
be tried again. That's you have to dumb it down completely. You
can't go to the actual things they believe on an individual basis
or you look like a complete [__]
You have to just stick at the very highest top level and only
say socialism bad. Ham bad, socialism bad.
Nick bad, fascism bad. Nick bad.
Hassan bad, communism bad. That's you. If you engage at any deeper
level than that, you immediately look totally >> I don't
think I moral frog about anti-semitism too much because oftentimes
it's like CONFL YOU BROUGHT IT UP. He brought it up as his distinguishing
factor between JD Vance and Zoro Mamani for some reason. Even
if it was just a distinguishing factor for Zoro for JD VANCE,
YOU BROUGHT IT UP. YOU BROUGHT IT UP, YOU IDIOT. >> Plated
with anti-Zionism. So, I don't even know if I'm moral frog about
it that much. Uh, the terrorism apologia
that Hassan [__] does is repugnant.
>> Nick Fuentes openly cheered for Hezbollah. He openly
cheered for them. He was devastated when the pager attacks
He was just he was sitting there like, "Please do something to
Israel. Please get Israel, please." And they up and he was like,
"You guys got you guys suck." He was devastated when they couldn't
land more catastrophic damage on Israel. What do you mean terrorist
apology >> enough? I I I don't even like like I'm really
not trying to shift away from the argument. If you want to if
you want a
you you literally
brings up example of conduct that makes JD Vance somebody he
would vote for immediately is like catastrophically on that example.
Uh well, I I guess I want to move away from this, but I don't
want to make you think I'm running away from the topic.
yeah, Pisco is not even arguing. Cutter is realizing how stupid
he sounds in his own head as he says the things he says and he's
like, "Oh, I, you know, technically I guess I shouldn't be saying
that." Well, uh, let me think >> that,
uh, Nick Fuentes is a virulent
and that is categorically different to be an anti-sionist.
And you think that anti-Zionism is philosophically more defensible
and that Hassan [__] um denying mass but maybe making
evidentiary concessions to ane anecdotes of that Nick Fuentes
is worse in reference to anti-semitism.
I could concede that in my point. I >> say it's it's not
even arguable, right? Because look at all the comments when >> if
you ever find yourself in the place where you're saying I could
concede that, you know, somebody who's been a mainstream creator
for the past like decade might be less anti-Semitic than Nick
Fuentes, I guess I would have to concede that. If you if you
find yourself in that position, holy [__] where have
you gone? Where what have you done? Uh, by the way, I'm not Jewish.
I'm just want to say I'm I'm not I was baptized in the Catholic
church. I um, you know, I'm Hispanic. And not with any of that
whenever there are people you know replyers saying shut up things
like that. Do I think where where are those coming from? Are
the shut up Jew comments or uh the whatever the happy merchant
memes are they coming from the super far-left communities. Most
of the times I'm No, they're coming from the GER communities.
And this guy is actually close to power on this issue >> It's
he's close to power in a way. >> I feel like I feel like
you're on this
>> Um sorry real quick. um they're not going to say shut
up. They're going to say shut up Zionist. But then within the
same breath or the same paragraph or the same video essay, they're
going to say 80 to 90% of Jews and 80 like 98% of Jews in Israel
and 80 to 90% of Jews in the diaspora are Zionists.
So So they're they're not saying all Jews because they have 20%
of the diaspora population and 2% of the Israeli population that
are anti-Zionist. So they're not
>> So hold on. Let's say hypothetically just grant me for
the sake of argument here
that Israel is just like openly committing atrocities. Okay,
I'm I'm not saying they are. Okay, even though they definitely
are, but let's say they are.
At what point is it okay to be like totally anti-Zionist in a
way that is denigrating to Zionists despite the fact that the
ethnic overlap exists? Cuz there has to be a line. You're just
arguing we're not at that line yet. You there's no way you would
commit principally. Like if they just actually started bombing,
if they nuked Gaza, you would have to criticize that, right?
You would never go, "Oh, well, being anti-ionist is still evil
because a lot of Jews are Zionists."
That can't you can't possibly have that opinion. That is a stupid
opinion. Talking about old Jews. They're just talking about 80%
of the diaspora population and 98% of the Israeli population.
And they'll use that as an invective insult. M. So, I mean I
mean that's interesting because I just I heard you just then
say that uh JD Vance is like a Zio shell. Did you say that? >> I
think so. Uh was that was that you
sure most Trump admin is Zioshell? >> Was that you signaling
a dislike and disdain for people in conflating that issue? What
were you doing there? >> No, I I think I think that there's
an actual Okay. I I think there's a legitimate difference um
between Zionism and being a um and I think that the 20% if you
called that 20% of diaspor
1 to 2% of Israeli Zionists they would actually just definitionally
not be the case. So I think there actually is a categor categorical
difference. Um, and then also Zioshell. What I'm trying to communicate
there is that there are things that Israel does that are definitely
criticizable uh that would be criticized of any other nation
state. And yet it seems like there are Americans who are either
paid or politically incentivized to never criticize the state
of Israel.
Why does Connor insist on doing this on like bringing a topic
up going down like some alley? He like
he like turns down Red Alley knowing there's a there because
the racist is
Like I I just can't I can't get over watching this stream. Like
what how
what a part of of what part of this is attractive to people.
I don't I literally don't understand. I'm like actually losing
it. I want clear. So So when you call someone a Zio shell that's
you're not being antisetic. That's >> Yeah. I I muted myself
so I didn't have the ability to answer. I don't care if I'm being
anti-Semitic. Uh >> I didn't ask if you're being I didn't
ask if you cared about being anti-semitic. I >> I don't
think I'm being anti-Semitic. I wouldn't be surprised if some
people called me anti-semitic. >> But you but but be honest,
your view is that you're not being anti-semitic when
>> I I don't I don't think I have an antipathy I don't
think I have an antipathy towards Jewish people. No. If anything,
I'm like a a fellow.
>> Okay. So, hold on. Wait. How does he even How does he
even accuse Hassan of this? Okay, Hassan has friends. He does
the same thing. I say Zionist, but I don't have like a hatred
for people.
What is the What is the difference? You use it as an you use
it as a like joking invective, right? Like you I'm guessing he
he'll say Zio is like tongue and cheek, but that is taking what
is essentially a slur used against people who do shill for the
state of Israel,
I What?
And you say you don't have antipathy for so it's okay. But Hassan
says he doesn't have antipathy for you go well he technically
had this evidentiary concern on October 7th that he's walked
back.
I probably give too much of a pass.
>> That's not me. That's them. >> Give me a second.
Hang on. I will try. >> Yeah. is where are we or to to
say the same thing a zio shell and but and if Hassan were to
say the same thing about just say for instance Ethan Klein or
to say for instance Chuck Schumer do you think that that would
be anti-semitic under your lights? Uh kind of uh and and the
reason why specifically if you'll indulge me a second um Ethan
Klein has said that he wants a two-state solution. He said that
he doesn't endorse the war crimes of the IDF. He said that he
wants the IDF to withdraw from Gaza and the West Bank. He says
that he u not only >> JD Vance has criticized Israel. JD
Vance has said that um we need to take a more America first policy
and that and that we can't be pushed around. He has praised Donald
Trump for for not being pushed around by Israel. JD Vance has
signaled in the past that he's more critical of Israel than um
than Donald Trump. So you can make >> hypothetically are
you saying this
>> These are all true things I just said. Well, number
one, I don't know if those things are true. Um, number two, I
would say that uh,
>> wait, hold on. JD Vance has refused to come out and
condemn Nick Fentes.
JD Vance has been asked directly. We know he's been asked directly
and he has not come out and condemned Nick Fuentes in like a
significant way. I think,
wait, or maybe he has. Did he just come out and do it? I I remember
hearing that like he he said, "Oh, like of course I hate this
guy." But it was through somebody else's like words. I'm pretty
sure he didn't do it. I think it was like his friend, right?
It's the clip we watched yesterday.
He's like, "Oh, his friend was like, "Oh, yeah. Listen, of course
I hate Nick Fuentes." Bro, I I don't I don't understand. I'm
I'm getting like lost in the sauce trying to understand. I Sorry.
I'm trying to construct like a consistent position for Connor.
I'm trying to understand and it just can't be done and my brain
is like
it's it's like I divided by zero in my head right now. Ethan
Klein in my opinion has about the only it's not even a sane position
because he actually has argued in the past that he thinks that
Westbank settlers
um even civilians even women and children can be treated as military
targets. So, I actually think that uh Ethan Klein actually has
almost an extreme anti is >> he has
of an anti-Israel position that you can have.
wait, Ethan Klein thinks you could target kids. Wait, >> I
thought the whole thing they virtue signaled over. Wait, was
he talking about Hassan talking to Ethan Klein? I missed it.
I missed it. I missed it. I missed it. There's no way. There's
no way. There's no way. There's no way. >> It's not even
a sane position because he actually has about to
Um, well, number one, I don't know if those things are true.
Um, number two, I would say that, uh, Ethan Klein, in my opinion,
has about the only, it's not even a sane position because he
actually has argued in the past that he thinks that Westbank
settlers,
um, even civilians, even women and children can be treated as
military targets. So
there's no way Ethan Klein talked about baby settlers being valid
targets when Hassan hasn't even done that and he got away with
it. There's no way that actually happened. That that can't possibly
be true. I don't think even though Hassan's got no motion, he's
got no a loggers. He's got nobody who helps him out. Even though
that's the case, you would think there's no way they got to virtue
signal over the baby settlers comment with Assad. And Ethan Klein
supported baby settlers or sorry, he he talked about how baby
settlers were valid military targets.
>> There's no way, right? I actually think
>> Ethan Klein actually has almost an extreme anti is >> he
has
of an anti-Israel position that you can have while still supporting
the general existence of Israeli state. And so I think calling
him a Zio shell is I think it's
regardless of whether or not you call it anti-semit. Actually,
you know what? I I do think it's anti-Semitic.
I you're you're taking somebody who's potentially an ally and
you're calling them as bad as someone who wants to annex the
West Bank and annex Gaza. Yeah, I think that's up, hypocritical,
>> I don't think that's entailed by saying zoshill. I mean,
I think that um people might mean different things when they
say Zioshell or calling people, you know, supporters of of Zionism
or whatever, right? It's like it's like getting paid in order
to espouse beliefs that you might not believe. It's like a >> perverse.
What's What's your evidence that What's your evidence that JD
Vance is getting paid by by Zionists? >> He might he might
not be. Um he might not be getting paid, but I think there's
political incentive. >> I mean, Trump is getting paid by
Zionist. Would you call
Uh sorry, real quick. I I just want to make sure that I'm using
this word correctly. An accomplice of a hawker, gambler, or swindler
who acts as an enthusiastic customer to entice or encourage others.
So, so yeah, I don't even necessarily It's like purely financial.
I I might I might describe Trump as a Zionist.
>> I I might describe Trump as a Zionist shill and that
he's literally taking money. Okay, so we agree that there's if
you are taking money, so for example, if you're taking a great
deal of money from
uh institutions, you would be comfortable calling that
Zionist shillism
for any politician. >> Well, I would say money or political
clout because I don't think it just has to be money. But yeah,
if you're like an
Israeli propagandist who cannot bring yourself to criticize the
state of Israel, then yeah, I I think that zoshill, while it
might be a derogatory term, it's probably an accurate term. >> Okay.
Well, this is such a reminder. His big issue with Hassan and
people around Hassan is that they use in they use Zionist as
an invective and that in encapsulates all Jews incorporates all
Jews or essentially all
like I principally I just don't >> derail from the from
the broader point that you could take this view that JD Vance
is less racist or just as racist or like put it even just put
the racism to the side and put the shillism thing to the side
and put the um technology stuff to the side on just the basic
premise of ordered liberty liberty and the constitution and rule
of law. Shouldn't that be like our our guiding star and the and
the mere fact that you're willing to abide someone who is demonstrably
proven not just in your fantasies about Mao and your fantasies
about Stalin and your fantasies about um the goolags that are
imminent.
>> Thank god Pisco is actually talking down to him now.
He really >> upon us in the United States of America, but
actually proven
>> even like, you know, we're talking about real things,
not your your weird hallucinations about >> multiple different
instances.
>> That they're willing to totally disregard the rule of
law.
the fact that you're willing to abide these people and consider
them in the future as potential votes. That can't be um correct
on your view that the liberty and framework of this country matter
the most.
>> If you were Okay, so number one, I think that you classifying
threat to liberty as like a decent motivator, u I think that's
true. Uh I think that would actually be my calculus. My legitimate
calculus would be who is the bigger threat to American liberty
and then I I would actually make a a calcul like a
>> in what world is that Newsome over V over Dance?
>> Um I Okay, we we should probably make this a totally
separate discussion. Um but I would say that you guys just don't
believe in the power of the Second Amendment. You just don't.
You just >> God, I it's it's so crazy. It's so so so crazy
how many presidents have to go through as Dems and never ever
ever ever
pass any consequential gun reform. In fact, Donald Trump, who
passed more consequential gun reform, Donald Trump or Joe Biden?
Cuz I could have sworn there was a bill. Didn't Donald Trump
get rid of like uh Oh, what did he get rid of? It wasn't bump
stocks, was it? Was it bump stocks for Trump? Did he get rid
of bump stocks? Trump had like gun control reform. like he had
some legislation that went through. Okay. So, so in what universe?
In what universe?
>> Do we expect a a dumb politician to do more than that?
Where >> rolled it back eventually? Okay. Rolled it back
eventually though. Okay. >> don't believe in the power
of the second amendment. And if you check Federalist 29, if you
check Federalist 46, I would strongly recommend before we uh
before we have a discussion about the Second Amendment, you should
read Federalist 29 and Federalist 46. >> Why do you call
the the Second Amendment over the First Amendment? Like listen,
Vance is supporting the policies of like shipping people off
because of their support for Palestine. Vance is in support of
impeaching judges and removing them because they come to decisions
that he doesn't agree with on the law. He has argued as recently
as this year that at at a certain point we have to start talking
about not listening to the courts when they're ordering the president.
So in what's why is this asks questions he doesn't want answered
he
he definitely should have right
like hold on I feel like Pisco is up here a little bit right
Pisco up a little bit in that he asked the question Connor was
about to answer and Pisco goes no no I don't think Pisco's like
I have a whole rant about how JD Vance is like actually doing
this when Connor was like okay yeah I agree he's doing that and
I'll answer and Pisco's like no no I need to do that >> this
extra bit of uh Connor protection than like basic first amendment,
basic rule of law, basic structure of our government like you
understand.
I guess Pisco does this as a rhetorical flourish to say like
you're doing this. And Conor's like, "Yes, I am doing that."
And he's like, "Wait, I need to explain to you how moronic you
are for doing this before you actually agree and say this is
why I'm doing it." Okay? because I I think probably if you understood
how much of a [__] you'd have to be to support this,
then you'd not support it. >> Now, the only reason that
any of the rights are able to be um applied is if we have a robust
separation of powers. You can't raise a second amendment claim
if you don't have access to courts that can actually um stop
the excesses of whatever government you're talking about. So,
as a i.e., Pisco should use the exact example.
These
want to take away guns from trans people on the basis of transgenderism
being like a significant mental disorder. Do you believe in that,
Connor? Should you take guns away from trans people, Connor?
They don't even believe in the Second Amendment. They don't have
principles, which is what makes them so dangerous. So you saying,
"Oh, well, I think I think JD Vance has like principles. I think
he's like more tepid." He doesn't have those principles. There's
a bunch of advisers around these people who want to get the guns
away from trans people. And guess what? Then you've then you've
normalized taking it taking away guns from anybody who has like
any sign any like mental disorder. Now it's just a matter of
getting the DSM5 to include other things. Hey, alcoholism. We're
we're considering addiction like a mental disorder. Now, if you're
an alcoholic, you actually can't have a gun. >> Starting
principle, you should be more concerned with separation of powers.
um
>> how many subs for another hour? I don't know. It says
up there >> taking of complete unilateral control by one
branch and the distortion of the framework. Right. >> We're
up late. I'll if if we like I'll finish this debate. Okay, hold
on. We we'll finish this debate, but if you guys don't want to
pay for more time, I'm like I'm down to just peace out after
this to be honest with you. So, I want to I want to keep streaming
more. Actually, I should say I want to keep streaming more, but
I'm not going to do a whole bunch of shilling. I just want to
actually watch the >> separation of powers. um the taking
of complete unilateral control by one branch and the distortion
of the framework, right? The the Bill of Rights are an afterthought.
The Bill of Rights aren't ratified at the time of the of the
framing of the Constitution, right? It's it's an afterthought.
It's a concession that is later implemented. What's more important
to this country even than the individual rights guaranteed by
the bill of rights is the framework and structure of the of the
constitution which JD Vance that is the structure that he's attacking.
He's attacking it in terms of the the checks by congress in their
appropriation powers. You talk about the department of education.
Yeah, you think it's based but it's it's a total abdication.
>> I don't by the way I don't think totally gutting the
DOE is based saying that people in the rightwing do. >> Okay.
But JD Vance is ignoring as long along with the Trump administration
the commands of Congress.
>> Uh Matt NLT, thank you for the 10 gift. That's an easy
way to do it. You just donate way over what the number is. Base.
Thank you very much, Matt. Appreciate it. 2 hours 5 24. Let's
go. >> They're ignoring the commands, of course. And they're
saying,
>> uh, hold on. I wasn't Thank you so much, Matt. I really
appreciate it. Okay. I need to pop off more when I get donations.
Okay. I need to show appreciation. Thank you so much, Matt. Really
appreciate. might not even listen to it. That's a more that's
a bigger threat to your Second Amendment than any legislation
that a Democratic president's going to propose. Cuz at a bare
minimum, a Democratic president who proposes that legislation,
they're going to listen to the courts when they strike them down.
Similar to what Biden did with the student loan stuff. And so,
you should be much more concerned if you're really second amendment
build. You should be much more concerned about a government that's
willing to ignore court orders cuz how else are your second amendment
rights going to be
Okay, you and actually this gets to like a structural.
Pisco's got like, you know, there's Maslo's hierarchy of needs.
Pisco's got his his uh Pisco's hierarchy of rights. Okay. Courts
don't work. None of your rights work. Hope you get it.
>> One of the ME1K sub drops any Jess could get one of
the ME1K sub drops any day. Nah, I don't think so. But I don't
need that. Okay. I just need I'm I'm a humble streamer. Okay.
I'm a humble drama farmer. We're just farming some drama and
politics >> issue uh that I think will remain a gulf among
like between us because I I don't think I'm changing my opinion
anytime soon. Um I doubt you're changing your opinion anytime
soon. Okay. So what I heard and I'm really not trying to straw
man you is you're saying that um the threats to governance procedure
the constitution the way our system works um that is more important
than a right enshrined what decades after the formation of the
country like weren't we under the confederation >> no no
so it was like >> before the bill of rights >> it
was very >> how long were we under the articles of
>> yeah the articles of confederation lasted for I don't
know five, six, seven, eight years, something like that, maybe
a decade. I'm not so the >> I thought it was >> the
constitution was ratified in 88 or
and it was enforced in 1789
>> and uh we >> Yeah. So, eight years there. So,
>> okay, sorry,
but but this is all after world not a single >> No, no,
this is this is all after first comes the constitution and you
know close in time in the first Congress. They pass the Bill
of Rights and they ratify those. But what I'm trying to say is
they're just listen to Scalia on this point because it's it is
important. They're just words on paper. What are rights? Right?
Like rights don't mean anything. They don't mean anything if
they're not enforced by actors and if they're not respect. >> Dude,
Connor just isn't >> did. And so in order to have >> and
it's gone down a totally like it's gone down a blind alley, too.
[__] me.
get back to Okay, comparing Hassan [__] to to Nick
Fuentes. Does he get back there? I wonder because like at this
point, you should be going back there, right? Like that was an
insane thing to say. There's so many things all of the things
that that Connor hates us on for Nick has done unironically.
I just I don't get it. That's I wanted to talk about that, but
apparently they're just going to go off on this this blind alley.
Many such cases with Connor conversations. First amendment,
>> second amendment, due process, all this stuff, these
guarantees, it presupposes
a robust structure of separation of powers where the government
is going to actually adhere to their promises on paper and that
is the foundation that someone like JD Vance Trump is attacking.
Maybe they >> we're not on this. >> Okay, but that's
why it's more important to protect that than it is any particular
right.
Okay. The let me uh let me address the second amendment right
after what I address next. Okay. Okay. So, you're you're saying
that uh Donald Trump and JD Vance have uh have and I agree um
attacked the foundational social contract by which we abide and
and I agree. And effectively what I view the republic as and
what I view liberal democracy and the United States government
and our society as is uh and I don't think you'll disagree with
this. I think you actually just said this um that it's effectively
a game, right? We're we're playing a social game together and
the game only functions as long as we have willing players. And
the problem with the game right now is that >> I mean it
only functions you're playing Monopoly with somebody who just
keeps taking money out of the bank over and over again. That's
that's >> Donald Trump, JD Vance, uh Steve Miller, and
a whole bunch of other people are saying we are not going to
follow the rules of the game. >> Wait, not just them? >> Yes.
until you force us to at the barrel of a gun.
>> No, I think they're just saying that if you force us
to at the barrel of a gun, we have more guns.
I I think it's like And by the way, you had been following the
rules of the game. And everybody before everybody there's a long
history. In fact, there's like a lionization of following the
rules of the game. Like no matter what, no matter how much the
sides have disagreed, they follow the rules of the game because
the last time they didn't, one of the sides decided not to follow
the rules of the game, there was a civil war, okay? And these
guys stepped up when realistically things were not at the Civil
War temperature and they were like, "Hey, let's just do that
again. Let's quote people from around that time. Let's Yeah,
let's just say that we're not going to follow the Supreme Court.
We're not going to do any of this. Let's just do that. It's court."
That's what we're >> And it's not just them. Peter Teal
explicitly said like we're in a postconstitutional era. I don't
believe in democracy. I think it's stupid. These are people that
you're
potentially endorsing as uh the next set of leaders at least
better than someone like Gavin Newsome who explicitly reject.
>> I would endorse I wouldn't endorse Teal, but if you
also watch Teal's interviews, because I've watched a couple of
them now, um he's exhausted by the DC game. He's he doesn't have
the will to power. He doesn't have the the desire to be a fascist
dictator. He's actually like he in the interview with Ross Duthad,
he actually says, "Yeah, man. I I back Trump super hard. I back
JD Vance super hard, but DC has frustrated me so much in what
how little we've been able to accomplish that I'm not even sure
if I'm interested in politics anymore. I think I'm going to go
back to my little [__] hav and play with my toys."
You you say that though he I mean he still has his contracts.
>> So little havl.
Uhhuh. I'm going to go back to my little havvel. Um the little
havvel is an actual unironically unironic evil villain layer
on an island in the middle of the ocean that's like a billion
dollars. It cost like a billion dollars to build. I'm hypothesizing.
I think I'd heard about that. I don't even know. Obviously little
reference to the seasteading stuff too. But >> he still
has Palanteer. He still has all that stuff. But even put aside
maybe maybe it's not teal. >> None of these people believe
in the rules of the game as you as you've described. They all
believe that those systems need to be ignored. Maybe you can
abuse them to the extent that it's beneficial for you and you
can like cite them as a token thing, but they don't care about
those rules. And that is the the key difference between someone
like Gavin Newsome and like what's the worst thing that Gavin
Newsome has done in terms of rule respecting? He didn't follow
his own COVID regulation and like went to have dinner. Like name
another Yeah, what else? Let me get to the second amendment part
then >> because because this is the through
>> The the second amendment is the um when people stop
playing the game,
private arms are how we build the new game. So, so, so eliminating
private arms,
the only reason why, like, and and this is actually like a libertarian
The only reason why, and of course you guys, well, not the only
reason why. The reason why people would be wanting to take away
private arms in their entirety or regulate them to the point
that they were not a factor is if they no longer wanted to play
the game.
And so that this is one of So hypothetically, I won't vote for
for Democrats. There's no way. Hypothetically, I wouldn't vote
for Democrats because by supporting gun control, they actually
are signaling they might not want to play the game in the future.
So, I'm going to support all of the people who are actively refusing
to play the game. The people who are actively doing the thing
that I think is the worst case scenario with Democrats possibly
wanting to do gun control. The fact that my party's already doing
it, I you know, if as long as Democrats are willing to entertain
gun control, I won't I won't support them. One of the things
that like >> like okay >> Democrats frustrate the
out of me on is like why are you why are you >> Connor
by the way Connor can't make this argument. I'm going to I'm
going to do something. Just know that nothing I advocate for
is is violence. Okay? Nothing I advocate for is violence. Connor
is explicitly saying the only way to stop my party is
civil war. Right? Like he's he's explicitly saying that he won't
vote for the Democrats and his side's breaking the rules. He's
saying he's essentially saying if they're breaking the rules
bad enough, you got to start killing people. That's so when when
people say that's what he's saying directly.
Uh if you actually think they're they're following the rules
or not following the rules, I wouldn't vote for you guys cuz
I'm scared you wouldn't want to follow the rules. My when my
side isn't following the rules, you know, nothing all that big.
I sometimes hem and haw about my vote. But because you guys might
not follow the rules in the future, I won't vote for you. So
the only if and if you think that's bad, if you think this current
status quo is bad, start shooting people.
>> Incredible stuff. >> If you're talking about like
for instance, Adam Schiff, why are you >> right? Cuz he's
saying if you come for the Second Amendment, we have to defend
it with guns. We have to defend it with arms. You guys, if you
think the rule of law is important, you should be shooting people.
You >> talking about an assault weapons ban when you think
we're on the verge of a fascist takeover.
What the are you talking about? because arms is how you reset
the game and play a new game. So why are you taking away that
tool? That's the dumbest thing possible.
And until
left-wingers and liberals, because I actually think that they're
to some degree like allergic to violence, until you realize that
righteous violence is what makes our game work, and until you're
willing to Okay, sorry. I just so you know, I'm not crazy. Thank
god he's just saying it directly now. I thought he was going
to leave it coded because I thought he liked having a YouTube
channel, but he is just saying it directly now. Okay, thank you
Connor. Thank you. I thought I I thought I was reading tea leaves
for you guys, but actually he's just going to come up and say
it directly >> to engage in righteous violence.
>> Now, I don't even think that this is ne I don't necessarily
disagree. I'm super careful about this stuff cuz I only have
one platform left. Okay, I only have one platform left. So, I'm
very careful. I don't want violence ever on any certain for any
reason. >> Perpetuate the game in >> and I have to
keep saying that. I will keep saying that. It's my Dr. Mike moment.
Okay. I don't believe in violence. I I'll never advocate for
violence. Uh you'll never get me to say something different on
the topic. Drop >> To start a new game, god forbid it all
falls apart. We are not on the same moral foundations.
>> So, you think that the fact that people like Schiff
are targeting gun rights by doing this weapons ban? I'll have
you know, you know who else supported assault weapons ban? Kla
Harris. But you made a calculation. You made a calculation that
the threat posing to get it through, >> right? So why isn't
that operative now? Why isn't that operative under a proposed
President Nuome that if you >> because Connor is operating
politically the exact same way Hassan [__] does when
he says he's not going to vote for Democrats. He is trying to
advocate for his political beliefs and he's saying I'll withhold
my vote to do it. and he won't if he actually has the principles
he stated. Now with Connor versus Hassan, at least Hassan, you
know, has consistently gone a voted Democrat. Connor hasn't stayed
consistent on any principle in his life at any point ever that
I'm aware of. Okay? I've seen him state a lot of principles that
he is totally violated.
I don't trust him. There's no reason to believe in him. He's
a loser. Okay? Hassan, at least I've seen with Hassan, I can't
think of as many contradictions off the top of my head. I'm sure
there are. I'm I'm sure there are. Listen, I don't think Hassan's
a particularly principled person. I just think he's less disgusted
than counterpoint. >> I'm going to evaluate it as it comes
and ideally by having conversations with people like you. I know
I only have 100 live viewers, although like I said, they're incredibly
generous. Like the stream, share with your friends, engage with
chat, super chats if you got them, memberships if you got them.
Um, the goal of course is to be a six figure or maybe eventually
like a seven figure creator, right? That's the goal. The goal
is to be Tucker Carlson. The the goal is to be Destiny. The goal
is to be Hassan [__] goal is to not just have internet
influence but to have conversations with real power brokers and
change
>> not happening. Uh it could happen. I will say Connor
has an endurance okay that is particularly good to be a creator
like he will he will show up to get beat he's like um oh [__]
there's there's probably good examples of this. He'll show up
to get beat up like anywhere at any time for any reason. That
could probably make you fairly big. I'm trying to think of people
who are like that. I can't off the top of my head. their minds
about the way they think about the world. So with Gavin Newsome,
you you're just going to have to accept the fact that I think
that liberals are wrong. The ends justify the means is essentially
what he argued. That's what he's argued at all times. That's
what he always argues. That's literally why he defends destiny,
right? The ends justify the means. I'm trying to build a channel.
I'm trying to get money. Eventually, when I have the money, I'll
be able to make things
It's like exactly what every single Congress person says when
they go and they're like, "I won't be corrupt." And then they're
like, "Well, I can do a little corruption and then I'll get like
more power. I'll get favors on my side and then eventually you're
just Nancy
They are incorrect
in what power is and how to wield it. And so until you guys shift
my way, I'm not going to say that I'm one of you. I'm not one
of you. >> No, no, no, no. That's not even what I'm asking.
That's not even what I'm asking.
Put aside I know that I'm not going to convince you. >> Are
you a pragmatic vote for Nuome? >> I'm not saying that
you could. Right. What I'm saying is you're not taking a vote
for JD Vance off the table. >> No, I'm not. >> In
a way that you would take a vote for Trump off the table.
>> That is what I take to be the confusion. The confusion
is thinking that the >> confusion because you're saying
that JD Vance would have helped him do the thing that I say is
the reason why I can't support Trump. >> Yes. Among other
things and worse
and he has worse worst people.
>> So Connor has now gotten to the point in the totally
unprincipled cycle. Okay, there's a list of steps you go through.
He's gotten to the point where he sees other unprincipled actors
who are operating under this ends justify the means. Okay, modus
operandi and he is looking at them and he is forgiving them for
their transgressions as well without even doing any investigation,
without trying to remain consistent. He is totally lost. He's
a drift at sea. He can't judge things correctly. He he doesn't
see how stupid he sounds, how uh he's like lost entirely,
right? Like he's sitting here explicitly saying,
"Yeah, yeah, well, you know, JD's got to do that cuz he's got
to maintain power." And I understand that cuz I do that, right?
It's just it's honestly if he
if he were a better person, I would feel bad about it almost.
I would I could almost feel bad. >> He'd be worse people
in his ear.
the well I number one I don't think it's going to be worse people
um but the they have h yes yes these people through incompetence
have killed hundreds of thousands or millions of people weirdly
enough that was also true of Bush um so the the thing about it
is like >> millions of people because of Bush what I don't
understand >> hund hundreds of thousands if not millions
so uh Bush through the war on terror arguably killed hundreds
of thousands of people >> so so my so my whole point is
um that yeah it's going to be an evaluative criteria. It's going
to be how far left is the left going. Does the left understand
power? Is the left willing to support the constitution win, lose
or draw? Are they trying to uh attack h like uh American liberty?
Do they foundationally misunderstand the country? These are all
going to be questions that I'm asking myself. And then what's
the potential harm of the left? And then I'll be asking what
is the potential harm of the right? And by the way, may maybe
I'm being um naive.
I'm really hoping this is the bottom. I'm really hoping this
is the bottom for the right wing. >> Really hoping it's
going to get worse before it gets better. Way worse. >> You
think how what what indication do you have that this is the bottom?
What indic Dude, what what indication do you have that we're
slowing down? That the changes are getting slower. Like you don't
even have a a change in the like second order measure. The velocity
hasn't slowed down, right? Or is it I think it's velocity. Yeah.
Like you're not you're actually accelerating downwards right
now. Okay. Acceleration. Acceleration. Your acceleration is increasing.
What you have to get the acceleration to decrease before you
actually get the velocity to decrease.
This guy is like not reached the speed of gravity yet. Dropping
to the ground. And he's like I think this is the speed of gravity.
I think this is the speed. I think this is like how hard grav
how much force gravity pulls with. Guys, it's not. It's not.
Dude, I'm trying to come up with metaphors on the fly. This >> a
dance real quick. >> If Donald Trump died, I I I don't
even know if you believe this. If Donald Trump died, >> speed
of gravity, you know what I'm talking about, right? The there's
like a there's like a a point at which you reach um terminal
velocity. Yeah, terminal velocity >> tonight from a stroke.
Natural causes passes out. Vance is president. You think JD Vance
would be a worse president than Donald Trump? >> The only
reason I think that maybe not is because he lacks the kind of
um zeal that Trump commands. But >> that's what I said.
That's the only reason in which I would be like, "Okay, I'll
take like just kick Trump out and let's deal with
>> that." But that's what I mean. I think he's more malicious.
Trump Trump is um almost predictable. He's Trump is predictable
and he's easy to charm and he's kind of an idiot. Um Vance I
think is he overinflates his intelligence. I think that he's
overrated in terms of how cerebral he is or whatever.
I kind of doubt that. I I doubt that. I don't think Vance is
dumb. I think Vance is like a fish out of water a little bit.
I don't believe you could be dumb and do the things he's done
in life. that that's one thing that I will give him is that I
don't think he's dumb. I think, bro, to go as like a guy who
grew up with like a crackhead mom who traded him for pills and
to become like a like a multi multi-billionaire and and vice
president by 40, I feel like there has to be something going
on, right?
I don't think I'd say he overinflates. I if anything, he's probably
playing dumb in some ways. Maybe. My god, please, please let
that at least be true.
don't make the the chameleon can't be >> But um there's
no way in general I'm not confident that this is a person who
I know how they work >> that I know and to the extent that
I know how they work it's like
>> as far as I know the JD Vance's uh Trojan horse into
the presidency was largely because he's a political opportunist.
it. You know, if you look at him, he shifted his ideology two
or three times over the past of the past two decades. >> There's
no way that all of the reasons that we just laid out on this
stream that you can't possibly trust JD Vance,
that Connor is aware of them, and his his predicate, his his
pretext for trusting JD Vance was, "Oh, I think he's less like
um
I think he's less extreme than Donald Trump." And then he goes,
"Actually, JD Vance really is like totally shifty. You can't
put nails principles down at all. He he he flits from here and
there, from here to there. He's basically Sneo. He's a leaf in
the wind. Calculated leaf in the wind, but he's a leaf in the
wind.
Dude, how is he aware of it? And he doesn't actually it doesn't
change his opinion.
>> Uh depending on what was politically expedient. Uh what
um as far as I know, as a Trojan horse for the Tealites, his
job was tech deregulation and leaving Silicon Valley alone and
maybe some tax breaks. That's what I think was and Teal already
got his like Palanteer contracts. He already got all this kind
of stuff. Uh so so my question is that damage is done. What what
guys Bisco, how bad could JD be? We've already reached maximum
teal corruption. Okay. Teal literally can't rap us anymore. He's
already Listen, he's already inseminated us. He can't do it anymore.
We're fine. We're totally Listen, my belly is already full of
disco. Okay. Can't be any more full. I don't think so.
Holy. The delusion is insane.
>> What is on JD Vance's agenda? The >> destruction
of the republic.
>> The what? >> The destruction of the republic.
>> Yeah. Literally the network state, the the they want
it bulcanized. They want America bulcanized.
>> This is a comment from real quick. Implicitly wants
to destroy the republic. To what end?
For what benefit? >> So, so
>> so that the unifor so that basically these feudalists
can have their little fdoms, right? Is the idea. They want >> First
off, this is what Dubie says. $50 super chat. Appreciate it.
Connor wants to return to post 911 wararmongering neocon head
assery. Trump isn't ideological. Vance is full-on dark enlightenment
technocratic nut and he he's far more intelligent. He'd do more
damage. That's what Dubie says. Uh you can respond to that or
what to say. So I I think that >> to what end? His own
enrichment. His own enrichment
being everybody listen everybody wants to be king. Okay. Everybody
wants to be a dictator. JD Vance could carve out they're going
to give JD Vance Ohio. He could do whatever he wants.
All right. That's like that would be the goal is to have be in
the the like teal hierarchy. Emperor Peter Teal is the idea.
Um JD Vance is interested in power. I think that he's interested
in breaking apart the constraints on that power and he's interested
in accumulating more wealth and um authority for himself and
for his friends. That's what he's interested in. That's obviously
what's motivating him is to wear this facade for the purpose
of getting more power. And him getting more power after Trump
has kind of like opened Pandora's box. Um I I think he would
actually potentially have the wherewithal and um and uh dedication
and patience in a way that Trump does not to successfully
um destroy the remaining guardrails of the republic.
>> Um so sorry I'm not trying to put words in your
>> critical rad. Thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go
>> mouth, but I'm kind of hearing this. You think that
it's power for
>> destruction of the republic? They're just going to grift.
I mean, that's explicitly not like, do you read any of the stuff
they write? Do you read any Have you read any of the Dark Enlightenment
stuff? Any of the Jarvin writing Act 90?
Why do you think Peter Teal pays Jarvin to advise him? Why do
you think he pays to fly Jarvin out to all these political
Do you think they're like just playing a game? You think that's
like, oh, they they like joke? Yeah, but nothing ever happens.
Okay. Well, I
this is called being an ostrich. You've put your head into the
sand. Okay.
I'm That's great that you think putting your head in this end
is a optimal strategy. The rest of us have eyes open. Okay. >> For
power's sake. I think it's power for the sake of power and but
not just of himself of also his friends and um promoting this
kind of like
conservative vision that is a little bit more
um in the weeds
uh intelligencia based
folk like Curtis Jarvin like he is a supporter and follower of
Curtis Jarvin right he I think is
They're like, let's just be real, okay? All of these guys are
pretending that they don't see themselves as Augustus, okay?
Every one of these people is Rome Pilled. They all think they're
Augustus or Caesar. That's what they want. They think they can
lead America to a great age, but it is foundationally below them.
The hierarchy of interest is them than country. And you should
not be voting for people who are going to consistently place
themselves above their country. If it does, if it goes bad, if
they the whole thing up and the world ends, they don't give a
[__] They're not looking to make America better first.
They're looking to empower themselves first. And then after they
have all the power and they get everything for America's success,
then maybe they can make it a little better.
That's what they want. Obviously, that's what they want. It's
what they've always wanted. My general thought would be that
Connor wants that, too. And Connor wants them to do that because
Connor is a surviile loser who wants a daddy. He wants Daddy
Augustus to take care of everything. Oh, Daddy Augustus, please
tell me everything's going to be okay. Yeah, it's going to be
okay, Kitten. You don't have to worry. That's what Connor wants,
okay? He wants his emperor. He wants his god king. That's what
he wants more than anything in the world.
Um, so, so this is
what,
um, I I've had a conversation with Jarvin, and I'm vaguely familiar
through people in chat. So what
uh what I think Yarvin believes based off of my conversation
and also what I I've heard of his writings and somebody can cor
you can correct me or somebody in chat can correct me is effectively
that there was an existent power structure within the pre-enlightenment
society and it was relatively ordered where you have God at the
top king beneath that the feudal lords all that kind of stuff
the peasant class this that the other and you had the church
and you had the family and so that social order while let's be
real medieval Europe was quite chaotic. Um, you know, it formed
like the cathedral of hierarchy effectively. >> And what's
happened in the, uh, enlightenment era is that those things have
been supplanted where God was, there's just a void that, you
know, nobody really specifically has to worship God. There's
kind of this like
Connor I don't Connor is incapable of understanding.
Okay, he's incapable of understanding these concepts and break
them down and taking the piece he needs to explain and just explaining
that
maybe this is good for a content creator, so I won't totally
on it, but it's so bad for general conversation where he has
to explain everything he thinks he knows from top to bottom every
single time.
You don't need the whole thing. You can just take what you need.
It's like this inability to distill down ideas is just it's like
um I don't know. You just don't have a spark. You're missing
something. You're missing something. And the conversations take
forever. And they already have totally left where they were before.
The defense mechanism. I think it is. I think that's mostly what
it is. He just wants to rant about something. I listen, I know
this cool thing. I've heard a lot about Yarvin. >> Oral
ephemeraless at the top. U there's the presidency and the secular
governments, but that doesn't >> Can I pause right there?
Can I just want to pause right there because you're using a term
the cathedral that Yarvin uses. My understanding is that they
do view that there's a cathedral in these modern societies and
that is the media that is the universities that is the um you
know the actors Hollywood and the establishment political class
>> and that's the old order >> right and and what
they want to do is replace those people with themselves for the
benefit of their elite class and to make them the feudal lords
over this tech anarchctic society. and they want to get rid of
democracy. Like Curtis Jarvin
does not believe in a republican form of government. Peter Teal
explicitly does not believe in a Republican form of government.
JD Vance is buoyed and
uh related to this
emerging tradition. So do I think that JD Vance has designs?
Did he just Did he just Okay, Connor is getting blown up obviously,
but with the obvious points. I'm actually annoyed at his face.
[__] this stupid loser's face. Okay, look at the
face he just made. >> Emerging tradition. So, do I think
that JD Vance has design? >> So, sorry, hold on. We didn't
go back far enough. >> Explicitly does not believe in a
Republican form of government. JD Vance is buoyed and ideologically
uh related to this
emerging tradition. So do I think that
>> Yeah, he looks he looks like he wants to disagree.
Shut the up. You cannot disagree with that. It is just a fact.
You want to disagree that he's buoyed and ideologically similar
to Curtis Yarvin and Peter Teal? You actually want to do that?
You stupid. Sorry. He looks like he wants to disagree. So, I'm
actually I'm actually annoyed at his thinking face. >> Dat
Vance has designs that are in line with his ideological goals
of power accumulation to his elite oligarch friends. Yes, that
is an existential >> Hold on. >> The the ideal of
course would be totally unmed from the Constitution of the United
States. It would be to destroy the Constitution of the United
States and eliminate even representative democracy. Okay, that
that would be the plan. But my my point is I don't think there's
any kind of political will because these people talk about political
will and and people and populism and all that kind of stuff.
They talk about that [__] all the time as well. I
don't think there's any kind of political will uh to reinstantiate
a monarchy. I don't think there's any political will to repeal
actually repeal the 19th amendment or the 14th amendment. I don't
think there's any political will to uh like repeal the first
amendment of the United States. And I think if they ever tried,
that would create such a catastrophic political backlash that
they would be swamped and kicked out of power almost immediately.
I think our republic is Wow.
So, I'm glad that Connor is agreeing that Hassan [__]
is no threat. Thank you. Thank you, Connor. Hassan Piker's no
threat and you have no reason to soy the out over Hassan [__]
ever
Thank you, Connor.
cuz I can promise you there is way more political will and thirst
on the right wing for that kind of authoritarian option than
there ever has been on the left. There is no concern about Hassan
doing that. There is every concern about right-wingers doing
that. Okay. >> It's powerful enough to kick those people
out.
But but it's not powerful enough to withstand uh arguably unconstitutional
gun law.
>> But oh, so hold on. While there is not general like
political will, if you did direct democracy, you couldn't actually
do that, right? You couldn't you couldn't actually do it.
But if hypothetically
you just kept pushing and pushing and pushing until things broke,
until it broke out into like a like realistically they're just
going to keep putting their knee on the neck of the country until
things disintegrate, right? Eventually you get something like
a civil war, maybe states break up, right? That's that's the
kind of thing that's going to happen. You could say there's no
political will for it, but eventually as things get worse, as
the economy gets worse, as people's lives get worse, as Trump
continues to destroy everything about the country, destroy the
economy, destroy everything, right? The social fabric will come
undone. Things will go to some kind of like civil war, and then
eventually you have like like sections of the country that stabilize
into something, right? Like they they're just going to keep breaking
it apart until it needs to reform as something else. They're
just going to keep degrading the their little goal will be to
degrade the life of the average person until they can no longer
stand the the status quo.
That's clearly what they're doing. It's what they've been doing.
>> Uh no, no, no. So, this is like uh this is a difference
in in what I'm talking about is that
because
I don't think the Teites
are capable of realizing exactly what you said. I don't think
they're capable of destroying the Republic of the United States
and I don't think there's any popular will for it. Um I think
that they would govern infinitely more technocratically where
effectively what they would do is they would carve out a deregul
a deregulatory
need.
So can somebody just ask Connor why did they not say that then?
Why do they talk about the network state? Why do they talk about
the country like breaking down and bulcanizing? Why are there
a bunch of them on the record that this is their plan? Why is
this a part of Yarvin's plan? Why do all of them have this shared
belief if they're just not going to do it?
Like, they're just they're accumulating power over time. I like,
dude, eventually it's going to get to the point what they're
trying to do. Like, just look at Bro, these people have no imagination.
Look at Rome. Okay, I hate to say it. I hate to be that guy.
I hate to be the cliche. Okay, look at Rome.
Oh, the labor is being devalued by the slaving by the by the
slave trade in Rome. Okay, labor is being devalued. people can't
make a wage. Eventually, when things get bad enough, you're going
to have somebody who gets a little bit of public trust, who's
blown up in the public eye, who's lionized in the public eye.
They'll come in and they'll say, "I have to take this over to
fix things." And then they're going to come in and they're going
to make things a little bit better for people. Okay? A little
bit better. A little bit better. A little bit better. That person's
going to continue to consolidate power. Oh, I can't let go of
power yet, guys. I'm going to have to keep I have to keep fixing
things a little bit. Okay? Actually, here's like, you know, we're
undoing these tariffs. Economy's coming back a little bit. Things
are getting better. I can't get low. Uh, actually, you know what?
Do you guys even want me to get rid of power? Do you want me
to not hear? Do you want to go back to the like democracy with
all these elites ruling you? Really? Why not just let me run
things for a while and then eventually, like once I die, it'll
go back to like once I die, you know, I'll I'll let myself a
couple consecutive terms. Once I die, we'll go back to the old
system. Okay? And then eventually
Baron Trump's his emperor. All right?
I'm just I'm telling you it's it's like the exact same plan.
It's not even confusing what they're going to try to do is for
teal. >> Yes. Yes. Yes. But they hold on. They need authoritarian
control before they get there. Trust me, it's it is going to
break up just again. Rome I hate dude I hate to say it. Governors
Rome is that guy will slowly pull back his his uh overall influence
in different places, right? He'll let them run his individual
Rome denied the two. There's so much overlap. History repeats.
>> Wait, history doesn't repeat, right? Oh >> Oh
god. Where where was I on this video? Hold on. >> Where
was I just now? Where was I?
>> Where was I on this video?
>> Hold the first amendment in the United States. And I
think if they ever tried >> that would create such a cat
for it. >> We're undoing these
>> that would
>> Oh, we'll go to 1 hour 5044 and go from there. Whoops.
>> One, they're not going to be successful. They're going
to spend all of our money.
>> Uh, no, no, no. This is like uh this is a difference
in in what I'm talking about is that >> because because
I don't think the Tealites
are capable of realizing exactly what you said. >> I don't
think they're capable of destroying the Republic of the United
States and I don't think there's any popular will for it. Um,
I think that they would govern infinitely more technocratically
where effectively what they would do is they would carve out
a deregula a deregulatory
niche
for Teal and for Musk as tech feudal lords uh to have reduced
taxes and government subsidies. >> That's not desirable,
Connor. That's not
>> Even if that were true, even if that's what they were
going to do, they they don't want to do that. Yeah, exactly.
The whole point of this will be to shift power away to weaken
the the overall authority of everything. That will be the whole
goal is to is to do this without political will to to
deceptively do this over time. They would never do something
overt like say, "Oh, Leo Elon Musk, he's like the feudal lord.
He gets fewer taxes. He's integrated into the government. We
get like part of his shares. We're they would never do that because
it's so overt things could be pushed back against, right? like
people there could form political will in opposition. The whole
goal of what they're doing is to not allow political will in
opposition to what they're attempting. That's what they're trying
to do. >> That's that's not desirable. Gavin wouldn't do
that. And the thing he would >> why would why would you
give a if Elon Musk off to Mars? Why would you give a if uh Peter
Teal created gay cat boys? >> they're gonna spend all of
So one, they're not gonna be successful. They're going to spend
all of our money.
>> Um, why would you care if uh private citizens are the
only ones doing like any new research and development and to
drone warfare and a bunch of other things? Why would you care
about that? Why would you care if like uh the the country didn't
really have the capacity to defend itself outside of like a private
citizen's army? Why would you even care? Why would that be a
problem? Oh, I can think of a few reasons. Kind of the whole
point with you and guns, right? You're basically arguing to make
the Second Amendment obsolete. Hey, I'm going to make this guy
really rich and powerful. He's going to come up with a bunch
of new technologies. AI run drone swarms that can overrun an
entire army immediately.
And guys, thank God we all have AR-15s. Okay, as as this group
of androids mow us down, one android takes out a thousand humans
in like 30 seconds. Okay, thank God. Thank god we've got AR-15s.
Let's go. and uh time trying to fail at that and they're going
to waste all of the potential things that we can do right now
and and basically accumulate wealth for themselves at the cost
of everything that we care about and we have to basically
live according to the whims of these egoomaniacal crab people.
>> well the thing is major Dr. Gassley. I don't know if
like I don't know if
or like this is this is starting to strike me as actually more
malicious. Like he is just trying to run defense for things that
he wants. Like he does want he does want the Warhammer 40k like
state of humanity. That's what he wants. He wants it to be just
like that and it's like actually just malicious instead. And
he's like pretending. No, there's no political will for them
to create like an Imperium, guys. There's no political will for
that. People don't want the Imperium.
uh under the table he's like Elon please if any please create
the Imperium. Sorry. The
if I if I added up all of the subsidies and tax breaks for Elon
Musk, how much of the federal budget am I going to hit?
>> The percentage
that's not Yeah, it's it's marginal compared to the overall >> in
the ocean. So, can we assume that >> how much you think
a Mars project is going to cost?
>> Hold on.
Okay. So, we'll put Elon Musk getting tax subsidies to go to
Mars against universal healthcare for Americans. We'll compare
the budgets, the expected budgets, and then we'll see which one
the people want. What do you think it's going to be, Connor?
What do you think it's going to be?
Um, it's really inconsequential to just give Elon hundreds of
millions of dollars to try to go to Mars. Okay. If it's inconsequential
to give away hundreds of millions or billions of dollars, then
why don't we do that to the American people directly through
healthare through like some universal healthare program?
>> What how much do you think a Mars Mars project is going
to cost? And even if it were just a hundred billion or $200
that's all of the USAD budget, that's more than it what's the
USAD budget? >> It it was 10 billion for PEPAR and USA
ID. $30 billion,
I'm sure. And let's see, what's the budget for Starship? Budget
for Starship.
Starship
Elon. It's five billion in research and development to date.
5 billion to actually get to Mars with a human colony. Right.
This is just on researching the Starship program, right? You
want to talk about getting to Mars? It's
>> in the ocean. Look, and by the way, we we might not
agree on whether or not we should be an extra planetary species,
but that aside,
okay, so for you're you're saying that you think that the Peter
Tu
I mean, the argument wouldn't be whether or not we need to be
an extra planetary species cuz there's been talk about going
to Mars for an hour. No, they've broached other topics. It's
not about whether or not humanity should be an extra planetary
species. Everybody agrees on that, right? The question is how
much of your current state like uh what do you call it current
quality of life do you want to sacrifice to become an extra planetary
species and for how long do you want to do it right like it's
fine you it doesn't matter pretty much everybody would agree
you should leave the planet except Makito apparently
but it's just like okay well if we have to sacrifice our health
our health and happiness for 100 years to do it well no that's
not really going to be cool I think that would be kind of actually
like I I'm sorry that would just be really I don't want to do
that >> JD Vance whoever um they're going to be trying
to destroy the Constitution of the United States and fray it
so badly that effectively we live in a new techn feudalist society,
which I I don't see the franchise going away. I don't see the
Constitution of the United States going away. What I'm what I'm
saying when it comes to Gavin Newsome, let's say Gavin Newsome
comes up with like, I don't know, some wealth >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait. Can you pause? Why Why didn't this convince
you on Trump? I don't see I don't see the de the franchise going
away with Trump, so I'll just vote for him. A lot of people did
that. >> Yeah, a lot of people did do that. A lot of people
in the center right did do that. Why? Because I care. >> You
You'd have to say, Connor, under this same predicate, Trump is
like totally everything you've you're saying Trump is furthering.
Literally everything you're describing as a positive future is
something Trump is working towards now in the present. What the
are you coping about when you say you're never Trump? It sounds
like you just don't like his face. Um, actually I have a personal
petty spite spiteful grievance against this guy. But anybody
doing this guy's exact thing is fine.
>> Because I care about international affairs. I care about
Ukrainians. I care about Africans. I care about the I care about,
believe it or not, I care I care about like >> uh what
does Elon Musk think about the war in Ukraine? Connor, would
Elon Musk be would Elon Musk have funded the war in Ukraine?
Connor, what >> like Republicanism?
I care about whether or not Republicanism and liberal democracy
get spread across the world and Trump was antithetical to that
>> JD Vance is a nivist.
>> Once again, like dude, are you blind TO >> ONCE
AGAIN, YOU'VE POINTED OUT A CONTRADICTION, a glaring contradiction
in my thoughts, in my moral framework, in my political thinking.
ONCE AGAIN, YOU HAVE EMBARRASSED ME, PISCO. PLEASE STOP. Please
stop. >> The fact that you have pieces of [__]
on your side because that's what it sounds like. It sounds like
you can't conceptualize
of a left-winger. So,
>> hey Connor. Hey, Connor. Quick question. Um, why won't
you vote for a leftwinger, but these rightwingers who violate
your principles are totally fine? Well, you see, here's why I
like them. Wait, you understand that applies to Trump, right?
Well, uh, there's pieces of everywhere, Pisc., WHY WOULD YOU
POINT OUT my >> Nefarious that a rightwing >> there's
basically no future.
Connor has to decide cuz these are the only two futures available
to him now. just completely unprincipled grifter
loser piece of or you're a total for ever abandoning Trump and
every influencer who says you're like a loser for abandoning
Trump is correct. You're either totally wrong for abandoning
Trump or you're a completely like hypocritical loser. One of
the two. >> Winger might be preferable.
Well, the one leftwinger that I know you'd vote for JD Vance
over
um is
>> I would vote for JD Vance over Mandani. Do you know
who I would vote for over JD Vance automatically, even though
he's a staunch gun guy or anti-gun guy?
>> Mark Kelly. >> You make no sense. You You're going
off vibes. You're making You're going off vibes and you're trying
You're rein
>> Mark Kelly definitely looks like somebody from Warhammer
100%. That's got to be it, right?
Also, isn't Mark Kelly the guy who said, "Listen, listen, guys.
Don't follow illegal orders as the military. We got your back.
Me, Mark Kelly, I got your back with absolutely no authority
to do
>> Isn't that what Mark Kelly to make sense of your this?
>> What are you talking about? Cuz he's a former military
guy. That's enough to charge because he's a former military guy.
Exactly. because what he's been doing over the past 72 to 96
hours. Okay. Mark Kelly took a principled stance against the
Trump administration. He told the military, "Hey, you might be
asked to do extra constit you might be given illegal orders and
I want you to disobey those. That is your job. That is your duty
through court marshall or death. It is your job to follow the
Constitution of the United States over the president of the United
States." He that is a that is just a statement of >> Yeah.
And and and who's and who's attacking Mark Kelly? Who's attacking
>> I'm going to glaze Mark Kelly.
>> And what happened after that is Donald Trump said anybody
who participated in the Sedicious Six like PR stunt deserves
capital punishment.
The Secretary of War said, "I'm going to call you back into service
and I'm going to make you do a uniform inspection and I'm going
to put you in front of a court marshal and I'm going to take
away your rank and I'm going to embarrass you and I'm going to
you over." And you know what Mark Kelly said?
He said, "You
said he didn't back down. He didn't sanitize it. He didn't make
it polite. He said that his oath to the Constitution of the United
States is greater than any pressure that the president of the
United States or the or the vice president or the the media establishment
or the um uh or anybody could put on him. And as a result, he
prioritizes the Constitution and his oath to the Constitution
of the United States that he served 30 years in order to do it.
He stood on business and he told the Trump administration to
go itself.
That's the kind of balls that we've needed. Not.
>> That's I Okay. Okay, bro.
I I'm sorry. I I can't I honestly now we're getting to the point
where I I'm having a hard time processing like what his positions
are. I don't understand. Like Pisco just said, I it's like all
over the place.
Now he loves Mark Kelly. What's Mark Kelly's position on the
Second Amendment? I I'm just curious. Has Mark Kelly ever supported
any form of gun control? I kind of doubt it because he's a military
guy, but a lots of the military guys end up end up going back
towards gun control stuff. Kelly introduces legislation to save
lives, protect communities from gun violence. Kelly's GO Safe
Act would protect communities from gun violence while safeguarding
Americans constitutional right to own a firearm.
Sounds like he's in favor of gun control,
huh? Weird.
Crazy, crazy, crazy, crazy. >> Not just from Democrats.
That's the kind of balls that we've needed from Republic.
my opinion, he's one of the few people, one of the few people
who has actually stood on business within our representative
body. So, while
>> is he he's like one of the few Democrats who has stood
up. Wait, Mark Kelly is a Democrat. No,
he he's definitely a Democrat, right?
I He's definitely a Democrat, right?
I'm I'm positive he is. I feel like I've seen him on committees.
Is Connor standing on business that Mark Kelly is the only Democrat
who stood up to Trump? Does he believe that? There's no way he
believes that. Is there
>> Oh, I will admit that uh Gabby Gfords is a staunch anti-gun
advocate. I would admit that he is probably anti-gun and might
he might even say the assault >> Oh. Oh, so it's just he's
totally
he's like actually just entirely Dude, what what principles this
guy does is this guy have any principles? It's literally just
who's the coolest guy. Who's the coole who do I who do I Carter
closes his eyes and he thinks about who could be his emperor.
And Mark Kelly's number one. Mark Kelly's number one. He's like
the coolest guy. Yeah, I he take my guns away, but I would let
him take my guns away. I love that guy. He's just so cool. He
was like, "Yeah,
you Pete Hexes, bring me back into uniform and bust my rank down.
Pete Hex, I don't care. I believe in the republic. Oh, I if somebody
was gonna be emperor, if if Mark Kelly wanted to be emperor,
I'd let him. Mark Kellyy's so cool. >> B [__]
If you're saying that JD Vance is a tealight neo monarchist who's
threatening the Constitution of the Republic of the United States,
what Mark Kelly did in the past 96 hours overrides
anything o overrides almost anything that I could see doing.
I'm very I don't
>> this is the gayest thing I've ever heard in my entire
life. And it's like actually just another reason there's reason
like eight in this in this one piece of content. There's like
reason eight that Connor has no business giving his political
opinion anywhere. He is he literally he
the best thing he could do for his country if he had any dignity
any honor the best thing he could do for his country is delete
his politics channel and stick to Warhammer.
If he had any honor or dignity whatsoever he would do this. He
will not. He is a hopeless, hapless grifter. No principles, no
honor whatsoever. Okay? He will continue to try to grift and
make money out of this cuz that's all he wants. He just wants
money. Okay? That's what he's here for. He's here for money.
Good lord. >> He's a socialist or a social democrat or
or any of that either. >> He would vote for Medicare for
all, but that's not so You would be like, "But that's not social
demically
socialism. Maybe
I don't know." >> Yeah. So, does does Pisco realize that
this guy's just a total loser and like actually talking to him
is a total waste of time. Everybody else has identified that
he has no principles, he has no beliefs, he cannot actually talk
through anything he thinks. He's operating entirely off of vibes
and then pretending otherwise. Okay?
Like if your net worth is your network, get this guy the out
to that extent then Donnie wouldn't be socialist either because
the only difference between him the policy he's hiding his power
level. >> Okay. Right. He's okay. Uh, so I'm glad that
you're um beaming with joy and pride at Mark Kelly's bravery
at standing up and doing the right thing. I'm I'm so glad about
that. Who from the whole country who's attacking Mark
>> This is why I don't know what did JD Vance do to get
the pass on hang out with a
>> Can you name some people who are attacking Mark Kelly?
>> All of the Republicans right now except for two or three
quiet people. And would that include JD Vance who said that what
they did was illegal.
JD Vance is attacking Mark. Kelly. So, so look at this and let
me finish this. Look at what Connor is trying to sell you. He's
trying to tell you, I'm willing to put aside all of Mark Pisco.
Pisco is like, "Oh, I got him now. I got him in a contradiction
now. Now it's been the whole conversation, Pisco. It's not just
now. I really got him this time." Kelly's hor like horrible policies
on guns, which before was like I had to really consider gun control
as opposed to fundamental opposition to the Republican to the
Republican system. I'm willing to look at past because he's so
brave in defending what the military is supposed to stand for.
>> Embarrassing. Yes. It's the most embarrassing thing
I've ever heard. He's so cool. I could see him. He could be my
emperor any day. He
puts fingers together. I'm just a small being when Mark Kelly's
in the room. When Mark Kelly's in the room, I he could do whatever
he wants. I love Mark
>> The principles of order, liberty, and no man being above
the law. So, he sells you that and saying that lets me overlook
all of the negative baggage of Mark Kelly. Okay? But he doesn't
have that same response in the negative to the very people who
are attacking Mar Kelly, namely Trump and JD Vance, saying that
what they're doing is criminal AND ILLEGAL. SO WHY IS IT THAT
your intuition and your pride is bolstered so much that you're
willing to overlook these otherwise disqualifying positions of
Marke Kelly, but the attack which triggers this pride isn't enough
for you to do the opposite with respect to those who are on the
offense in this illegal
uh sedition accusation. Tell me that. >> Yeah. Uh okay.
So because once again uh pro uh what is it?
Evaluations of personality. I think that 99% of politicians aren't
people. I I I think they're avatar. Bro, I just
I want to hit a soundboard. There just isn't a soundboard that
captures this moment. There really isn't. There's just nothing.
There's nothing that captures this moment. There's nothing that
really does it justice. I'm like looking for cuz like it's a
point of emphasis but he's just gone to the like well I don't
think we trust anything a politician says so I'm just going to
vote for the guy who's cool. That's that's Conor's politics.
I don't I I think all politicians are fake so I'm going to vote
for the guy who's cool in some given moment. I will I will give
Connor
He's kind of proved that I'm a complete [__] for
listening to him and taking his opinion seriously at all. He's
kind of shown me to be a complete idiot for sitting here and
watching this content and being a and then like debunking the
things he's saying. Like he has shown he's shown that I'm an
idiot for even giving him the time of day.
Wow. You got me. You got me, buddy. So embarrassing. Like actually
the most embarrassing political person online.
Tom Foolery is infinitely more principled than than
counterpoints. I would guess that the food shops is more principled
than Connor. Okay. I'm guessing
holy hell, man. >> Cars of ideology. Okay. Mark Kelly I
think is >> like he we just all watched him get slowly
like walked down. He's just basically said, "Yeah, you know,
I don't really have any principles. It's not about the the policies.
It's about this guy looking cool for a moment.
This guy looks cool for a second. So, I would I would vote for
him, even though he'd violate all of my principles. All my principles,
he'd violate everything. He wants to be violated by a powerful
man so badly, he can't stop advocating for it. Even when it makes
him look >> is a person. I think he's a human being. I
think he's probably based off of his actions and his history,
I think he's a man of honor. Um, and I think that if he was trying
to pass like legislation that I disagreed or whatever, he would
be doing it from like a principled belief that he earnestly believed
that this was the right thing. But also he's rooted in the Constitution
of the United States to the point of death. Okay? He thinks that
the Constitution of the United States is worth for. He thinks
the United the Constitution of the United States and the free
society that uh we live in is worth dying for. And he's proven
it through his service. So yeah, I'm going to take that massively
into account. Also, because he's a warrior, because he's a former
warrior, because he's a fighter pilot, because he's an astronaut,
because he's gone into danger. Um, I think that I probably could
sit down with Mark Kelly and we could talk about technocratic
gun policy and it
>> because you've done any of those things. Wait, Connor
did serve in the Middle East, right? That's I know he was a mall
cop and he totally overstates any of his actual duties as a police
officer. He completely overstates them. He's totally faked them.
He has lied on the internet about them repeatedly. Okay, I understand
that. But he did actually go to Iraq or something, right?
He surely he didn't lie about that part,
He served in the military, right? He went to Iraq or or Afghanistan
or some [__] No, no, no, no. He went to like the
as a janitor.
Well, did they teach him how to use a gun at least? >> It
wouldn't be this fslur
liberal soy complete misunderstanding of power and power. >> And
you couldn't sit down with Newsome.
>> The closest Connor's ever come to combat
having a disagreement over where a miniature was placed when
his wife bumped the table. Okay. He was playing Warhammer with
one of his buddies. He his wife bumped the table cuz she's a
stupid. Okay. And it knocked him a minute over and he couldn't
figure out where it was. That's the closest he's come to combat.
>> Understand power. He probably does understand weapons.
He probably does understand the balance of power between the
federal government and civilian
>> And you couldn't sit down with like Newsome or Tim Walls.
Tim Walls who's also the kind of military type type guy.
No, because Tim Waltz and Gavin Newsome have both made public
statements that they don't understand power.
They just don't. They >> What? I don't know what you're
referencing. They don't understand >> I'm referencing the
fact that Tim Waltz thought that it was a good idea in order
to show his firearms chops by going out in an orange vest with
a five round shotgun in order to ducks or >> shows he doesn't
understand power.
What are you talking about? He doesn't even understand the he
Dude, you have to understand how much of the right wing is rooted
in the culture of firearms. And you have to understand how
that was. >> You can go. It doesn't matter. It doesn't
matter. I'm not even talking about a culture that you're a part
of. I am telling you,
oh, he slung a shotgun over his shoulder. He put on an orange
vest and went quail hunting. Isn't he one of you? No, he's not.
Oh, Sean Ryan gifted Gavin Newsome a Sig P365
macro on his podcast and Gavin Newsome talked about
just ranting because he has showed himself anytime he talks about
anything in the abstract, anything in terms of principles. He
looks like a complete [__] [__] So, he's
ranting about individual stories, anecdotes so you can try to
fill out time and make Pisco want to go to bed. Classic Connor.
Okay, you'll notice your grandparents do this when they want
to get out of a conversation, too. Actually, they just do it
cuz nobody will listen to them. I'm guessing Conor's life is
a little bit like that, too. Some mix of the two. But he just
starts ranting when he's been proven to be every single time
is >> How he went shooting a couple of times with a 10
round magazine. No, that doesn't show me that Gavin Newsome.
>> Okay. Do you have a different pri you're using private
language? Because when people say they don't understand power,
I usually don't think the first thing like they don't understand
gun culture. But to you, power analysis and understanding power
means following the nicities or the customs and norms or the
safety instructions of gun culture and gun enthusiasts. I that
is a bizarre >> No. I think I think power I think power
is often very often probably nine times out of 10 maybe 10 times
out of 10. I think power is predicated off of like a understanding
of violence. >> Like uh >> we are we are a co we
are a collaborative species. We are I swear to God Connor is
sitting here. I'm not joking. And he's like, if you believed
any of this, you would have killed somebody already, so I don't
trust you. You haven't killed anybody yet. You don't really think
the Republic is falling. You don't really think this is serious.
Kill somebody and then we can talk. That's like Conor's unironic
I swear he's like throwing that in Pisco's face repeatedly. >> You're
also a competitive species and when collaboration ends, you have
to be capable of violence. >> When you were I Dude, it's
He's literally saying it repeatedly.
I It's not even coded. It's not coded at >> If you don't
understand violence, then you don't understand politics. >> So,
so you would say something like Conor McGregor. He understands
power more than Gavin Newsome. >> No, because he doesn't
know about guns because he's Irish. He also has an 80 >> Okay.
So, let me change it up again. Um, we'll say Dustin Porier. He
understands power in a way that Gavin Newsome never
>> Uh, I I don't Is Dustin Porier another MMA guy?
>> Okay. Well, the again I don't give MMA guys a lot of
credit when it comes to >> This is so weird. This is such
a leap. I think the better explanation you
is a leap. The better explanation is you think that Mark Kelly
is kind of like a badass like [__] masculine type
guy and Tim Wall is kind of like this. >> Bro, everybody
everybody should review this. Like all all political influencers
who who talk to counterpoints should should watch this. They
should review it. They should understand what they're dealing
with at any given point in time. Bro, I swear to God, I used
to listen to this guy talk and I thought like I thought people
were mean to him when that when that straight rage cherry conversation
happened and they called him a mall cop and and they made fun
of him. I thought people would be mean to him. Dude, he deserved
way worse than he got. He deserved way he deserved to be bullied
so much more than he actually got bullied. Okay. None of it was
enough. This soy little dad who hugs children. Let's cut the
Let's cut the What do you think power is?
>> Um, it depends the context in which you're using it.
When we're talking >> political power, what do you think
political power is? >> Yeah. An understanding of and um,
so an understanding of power. I take that to be
um a comprehension and apprehension of what it takes to get and
um you know your desires enforced in society.
>> Okay. And how do you enforce your desires in society
>> through various different mechanisms depending on whatever
governmental system you have in >> there's no reason to
talk to him. Pisco you haven't shot anybody. You you you you're
saying your republic is dying. People are trying to take your
republic from you. You haven't shot anyone. There's no reason
to talk to Connor. You don't understand power. Go shoot somebody
and then you can talk. Okay. This is this is the whole thing.
>> You know, passing laws.
>> Don't advocate for that, by the way. We don't advocate
for that. We think that's crazy. We totally disavow this. But
that is Conor's opinion. >> Uh ordering people with guns,
getting money extracted.
There's very different ways in which it's a broad concept and
different governments
uh sort of enforce the desires of the leader in different ways.
>> Okay. So when those mechanisms fail,
what enforces those mechanisms?
If the mechanisms fail, I don't I think by definition there's
a contradiction there. If a mechanism fails, how do you enforce
a mechanism that's failed? I don't Do you mean how do you enforce
those? If if somebody if somebody resists arrests or doesn't
pay their taxes willingly, how do you get them to pay their taxes?
How do you get them incarcerated and and in front of a >> You
force them.
>> Okay. So, we we at least got there. Okay. So, for force.
>> But it doesn't require a specific knowledge of
the ways in which forces applied at the micro level. It would
that's not what the like sort of means of power or like the the
analysis that we're talking about or I didn't understand it you'd
be talking about is like power in the sense of operational capacity
and use of firearms directly. Usually we're talking about politicians
and we're speaking of power. We're talking more of like the institutional
power or the ability to get people who do know how to do that
that thing to like work for you. Like we have a lot of fatties
and old people and people who never seen a gun or held a gun
are able to wield political power, right? Like isn't this Andrew
Wilson's whole stick? Yeah, but I don't even think Andrew Wilson's
that literal about it. Like ultimately this would be true. Like
if you have this the idea of like a military ha or whatever,
right? I think you say ha, not cha.
But it's the idea of that, right? You like a coup with the military
is if you have all of the force, if you have the threat of violence
on your side, you get power is like the idea. But it's it's there's
like abstractions layered on here that I don't think Connor Nancy
or something >> wielded political power. She didn't need
to know like the five gun safety rules or whatever.
>> Sure.
But I think Nancy Pelosi and any politician, and this is actually
like a frustration that I have with anti-gun people across the
entirety of the political spectrum, is that ultimately like at
the end of the day, if everything falls apart, then you have
to deal with the micro levels of force. So when you're talking
about taxes not coming in, you have to send law enforcement in
order to enforce taxation. When uh people aren't obeying legislation,
you have to send law enforcement in order to enforce it. If you're
being invaded, you have to have a military that repels an invasion.
If you have a riot or if you have uh anything like that, then
you have to have some form of security apparatus, whether that's
militia or whether that's launch. >> Granted, grant it.
I'll grant that. >> When collaboration fails, you have
to understand force. And what I think is missing from the private
arms component is that again, I would recommend you read Federalist
29 and you read federaliz federalist 46. >> I've read all
the federalist papers. Hold on, I want to finish this. This is
>> The whole conception of the second amendment, the whole
conception of Federalist 29 and Federalist 46 is that we are
a society that is capable of collaboration and competition and
p power must be balanced.
Power cannot be concentrated in an individual institution. Power
cannot be collected in a single political body or even a single
security apparatus. Power must check power. And so the ultimate
check against government power is an intelligent, educated, armed,
capable populace. And what it sounds like when liberals talk
about gun control, they're not saying, "Hey, let's become more
competent. Let's become more educated. Let's be more capable
of force. Let's be more Let's Is it is like I can't tell. There's
another read of this is like Connor's basically like, "Hey, I'm
I'm not joining your side until I think you guys could actually
win a civil war. I think you guys would lose a civil war really
badly, so I'm not going to join your side." It's like Connor,
your side would you first in a civil war. They wouldn't even
fire at liberals. They would you first. You are like the biggest
You are like the biggest loser to them. They would just you.
They're not looking to They're not looking to Pisco before you.
At least Pisco is delusional. You seem to understand things and
you're a traitor. Like I
>> Let's understand force and violence more desperately.
It's more of I want to ignore this part of the human condition
because I don't like it because it's uncomfortable.
And the fact that we have people in power like Gavin Newsome,
the fact that we have people in power like Joe Biden, Mr. Put
two buckshot rounds through your front door so the bad guy doesn't
come in. They don't understand the micro level of violence and
therefore they misapply the macro level of violence. Sorry, real
quick. When when uh when he says when Joe Biden says, "Oh, you
think private arms are going to do anything? You have to compete
with F-15s.
He doesn't understand violence." That's the leader of the free
world. That's important. So, yeah, I think Mark Kelly understands
violence.
And I think that Gavin Newsome wants to create a more
miseducated
population. So if there is a right-winger who understands these
things and is going to have wor like better technocratic policy,
I'm going to vote for them. If you want me to vote in some
soyed fsler who doesn't understand power, I'm not going to. >> Dat
Vance, he understands power because he's had military training,
I guess.
>> I mean, he's he's a former marine. He's a pogue. But
yeah, he pro he probably understands the micro level of power
relatively well >> in that he's able to wield a gun. And
you don't think that he probably >> you know that Tim Walls
was a firearms instructor. He was uh a sharpshooting in
>> I Okay, I'm probably just done with
Um dude, this dude, the internet's like such a blackpilling place.
I I can't sometimes, man. This whole conversation is really up.
Give me a second. We're going to shift gears. Probably shift
gears here.
Let me see. What do we got left for time? I think we're going
to have more time coming up here. Give me a second. Yeah, we're
like a sub away from another hour on the stream. Come the Candace
Owens stuff. At least read her tweet out.
Dude, the Candace I I'm so I'm so tired. I'm so I like this this
dude. Con Connor like actually saps me of my will to live at
this point. The fact that he could be such a transparent grifting
loser and make all of this and like apparently he's making money.
Maybe it's it's just so disgusting. He's such a disgusting human
being. Um but it's fine. Uh I'm going to grab a drink and uh
caffeine. going to grab some more caffeine and then I think I'll
let this play for a little bit and then we'll try to go to well
we'll read the cand stuff and then we we have like the food shop
stuff with Dan having a fight with Dan which is very funny.
Um we'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. We'll
see.
Um,
I think food shops doesn't understand that they're like basically
wrong about everything they say all of the time and they're going
to try to make a point of this and they're going to get brutally
raped because they have admitted multiple times attraction to
at least drawn depiction of kids and they self-prescribe drawn
depictions of kids drawn depictions of kids to themselves to
deal with their POCD which is essentially like a a compulsion
towards finding like having thoughts about kids. So, she thought
that off to was going to be her way to no longer be attracted
to kids,
right?
So, I I mean, we'll see. We'll see. I guess I have to go get
context on all of this cuz I don't watch those streams. So, I
give me a second. I'm going to grab all of the links here. Other
people are sending me links, so we'll take a look. But, it's
just very funny because I think I think they don't quite understand.
They banned me from their chat today. Uh uh, okay. They banned
you from their chat.
I mean, you were in their chat. Why were you in their chat? Who
is this? I'm I'm I think I'm just going to throw You have to
tell me why you watch them because I I feel like I'm probably
the best case scenario here is you're just like a L who's had
enough. All right. So, I have like the ban button ready. Why
are you here?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. This is like
the Red Army. This is like the Red Army. Okay, if you've been
in if you're hanging out with food shops chat, you're actually
getting shot here on site. Okay,
this is this is you're not welcome here. I am an oldtime viewer
of themselves. I Dude, you are like under the you trust me. I
no longer hang out there for Okay. Okay, I'm hitting play on
this. I have to go get caffeine.
This person is under high suspicion. Extremely high suspicion
right now.
>> Okay. the dude the when you're talking about this like
I could write you a 10-page thesis paper on violence like right
now and we could talk about like small arms squad tactics, combined
arms warfare, we could talk about close air support, we could
talk about insurgency tactics, we could talk about infantry,
we could talk about maneuver warfare, we could talk about logistics,
we could talk about all this kind of you don't need to know all
that in order to be president, but you should understand at least
the basic level of where force emanates from. >> Got it.
We have a big super chat from Dubia again. Power. This is a quote.
Power comes from the barrel of a gun. Mao and Connor. Apparently,
it seems like Connor thinks power lies with the people ordered
to rather than the ones giving the orders. So, he ironically
doesn't understand power in the modern world. Response. >> No.
Incorrect. Once again, so uh Game of Thrones parable. Uh there's
a there's a sell sword, there's a priest, and there's a king.
And uh the sell sword is told by the king, "Hey, the other two
uh and a merchant, if I didn't mention the merchant, the merchant
says, hey, kill the other two. I'll give you more gold than you've
ever seen in your entire life. The king says, "Kill the other
two and I'll give you lands, titles. I'll give you a princess.
I'll give you endless amounts of political power." The priest
says, "Kill the other two and I'll make sure that you get into
heaven." Who does the cell sword kill and why?
>> You asking me? I mean, I know the answer that Varys
gives. >> Power lies where people believe it lies and like
that. Okay,
that's uh yeah, we don't need any more of